For resources and to support those affected by the California wildfires, go to smartlis.com slash wildfires. Hey guys, I just want to say welcome to all our fans overseas. I don't think there are any. Hang on a second. I don't think we've ever done a welcome to our overseas fans. Wherever you are, I know we get a lot of listeners and this is not a bed we get a lot of listeners in Iran and I will say we do have a huge listenership there we have a some listeners in in Germany we have some French listeners
For resources and to support those affected by the California wildfires, go to smartlis.com slash wildfires. Hey guys, I just want to say welcome to all our fans overseas. I don't think there are any. Hang on a second. I don't think we've ever done a welcome to our overseas fans. Wherever you are, I know we get a lot of listeners and this is not a bed we get a lot of listeners in Iran and I will say we do have a huge listenership there we have a some listeners in in Germany we have some French listeners|||有关加州野火的救援资源及如何为受灾者提供支持，请访问 smartlis.com/wildfires。大家好，我想对我们所有的海外粉丝说一声欢迎。我觉得可能也没有几个。等等。我觉得我们好像从来没向海外粉丝道过欢迎。不管你们在哪里，我知道我们有很多听众，不是在那种我们会拥有大量听众的床上——我们在伊朗有相当多的听众，我必须说我们在那里拥有庞大的收听群体，我们在德国有一些听众，我们还有一些法国听众。
Bonjour, ça va? UK, Canada, Australia. Well Canada is not over NEC but look at it. Okay sorry. And so but certainly the people that are friends down in Australia down under we have a lot of fans down there. How are you? A lot of fans in Brazil the home of the Brazilian and so just to all of our fans welcome to Smartless. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart.
Bonjour, ça va? UK, Canada, Australia. Well Canada is not over NEC but look at it. Okay sorry. And so but certainly the people that are friends down in Australia down under we have a lot of fans down there. How are you? A lot of fans in Brazil the home of the Brazilian and so just to all of our fans welcome to Smartless. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart.|||Bonjour, ça va？英国、加拿大、澳大利亚。呃，加拿大虽然不在NEC，但看看它。好吧，抱歉。总之，肯定有那些在澳大利亚——南半球的朋友们，我们在那儿有很多粉丝。你们好吗？在巴西有很多粉丝，巴西人的故乡，所以，向我们所有的粉丝说声欢迎来到 Smartless。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。
Lattice. Yeah, God, that was. Yeah, he's barely with us. Stupid Sean didn't know we had a record today. What did we interrupt, Sean? Were you in the middle of toasting Pop-Tart? No, I wish. I still have my things in, my trays in. Take, oh, yeah, take.
Lattice. Yeah, God, that was. Yeah, he's barely with us. Stupid Sean didn't know we had a record today. What did we interrupt, Sean? Were you in the middle of toasting Pop-Tart? No, I wish. I still have my things in, my trays in. Take, oh, yeah, take.|||Lattice。对，天哪，那是。对，他整个人快神游了。笨蛋肖恩不知道我们今天要录音。我们打断了你什么，肖恩？你当时正在烤Pop-Tart（夹心小甜饼）吗？不，我倒是希望如此。我还戴着我的牙套托盘呢。拿——哦，对，拿掉。
It's not your trays, it's, is that Invisalign? Yeah, that's what I mean. Or is it just a bite, is it like a bite stick? No, I have one more tray to go. And then what, what are you working towards? Perfect teeth for when they lay you in the coffin? Is that what it is? Why'd you choose to do it in the last third of your life?
It's not your trays, it's, is that Invisalign? Yeah, that's what I mean. Or is it just a bite, is it like a bite stick? No, I have one more tray to go. And then what, what are you working towards? Perfect teeth for when they lay you in the coffin? Is that what it is? Why'd you choose to do it in the last third of your life?|||那不是托盘，那是……是隐适美（Invisalign）吗？对，我就是那个意思。还是说只是个咬合器，类似于咬胶棒？不，我还有一个托盘没戴完。然后呢，你做这个是为了什么？为了等你躺进棺材时有一口完美的牙齿？是这样吗？为什么你偏要选择在你人生的最后三分之一阶段来做这个？
They were pretty jacked, they were getting real jacked. No, they really weren't. You're just running out of shit to fuck with. Well, this is true, this is true. No, I panicked, I had a whole other thing and then I just got the text and I was like, oh my, there's no words, it's like getting a text saying. It's like you were sleeping through your alarm clock.
They were pretty jacked, they were getting real jacked. No, they really weren't. You're just running out of shit to fuck with. Well, this is true, this is true. No, I panicked, I had a whole other thing and then I just got the text and I was like, oh my, there's no words, it's like getting a text saying. It's like you were sleeping through your alarm clock.|||它们长得挺畸形的，变得真的挺畸形的。不，它们真没有。你只是闲得蛋疼，没别的事好折腾了。好吧，这倒也是，这倒也是。不，我当时慌了，我本来有别的事要忙，然后我突然收到了短信，我就想，天哪，简直无话可说，就像收到了一条短信说……就像你睡过头错过了闹钟一样。
Absolutely, or getting a text that says, where you at? You're on your way? Yeah. I'm like, oh my God. What do you guys do? How do you guys not miss appointments on a day? I usually don't. Do you, but do you, but why?
Absolutely, or getting a text that says, where you at? You're on your way? Yeah. I'm like, oh my God. What do you guys do? How do you guys not miss appointments on a day? I usually don't. Do you, but do you, but why?|||完全是，或者收到一条短信说：“你在哪儿呢？在路上了吗？”对。我就想，天哪。你们是怎么做到的？你们怎么能做到一天下来什么预约都不会错过的？我通常不会错过。你会吗，但是你会，但是为什么？
Why do you not miss them? Is it because you look at your calendar app the night before or morning of? Night before. Night before, yeah. Night before, and I get an email the night before as well from people I work with that say, here's what you got coming up tomorrow.
Why do you not miss them? Is it because you look at your calendar app the night before or morning of? Night before. Night before, yeah. Night before, and I get an email the night before as well from people I work with that say, here's what you got coming up tomorrow.|||为什么你不会错过？是因为你在前一天晚上或当天早上看日历App吗？前一天晚上。前一天晚上，对。前一天晚上，而且我跟我工作相关的人会在前一天晚上收到一封电子邮件，上面写着：“这是你明天要进行的行程。”
I do a week. Whoa, whoa, whoa. You're getting an email from people you work with that they send, so this is from your executive assistant. From Sweet Liz. And they say, hey this is from your executive assistant. From Sweet Liz. And they say, hey boss, boss man, here's what's coming up for you tomorrow.
I do a week. Whoa, whoa, whoa. You're getting an email from people you work with that they send, so this is from your executive assistant. From Sweet Liz. And they say, hey this is from your executive assistant. From Sweet Liz. And they say, hey boss, boss man, here's what's coming up for you tomorrow.|||我按周来看。哇，哇，哇。你收到的是你合作伙伴发给你的邮件，所以这是你的执行助理发来的。来自甜心莉兹。他们说，嘿，这是你的执行助理。来自甜心莉兹。他们说，嘿，老板，老大，这是你明天的行程安排。
I don't make her talk to me like that, I'm not like you. She sends me an email Sunday night, I get week at a glance. Oh nice. And she does. Like it's a TV show. Yeah, I get week at a glance and she sort of says, this is what's coming up in the next week, and sometimes even if it's a busy month and she sort of says, this is what's coming up in the next week,
I don't make her talk to me like that, I'm not like you. She sends me an email Sunday night, I get week at a glance. Oh nice. And she does. Like it's a TV show. Yeah, I get week at a glance and she sort of says, this is what's coming up in the next week, and sometimes even if it's a busy month and she sort of says, this is what's coming up in the next week,|||我可不让她那样跟我说话，我才不像你。她星期天晚上会给我发一封邮件，我能看到一周的概览。哦，不错。她确实这么做。就像看电视节目一样。对，我能看到一周概览，她会大致列出：“这是接下来一周的行程，”有时候甚至如果这个月很忙，她还会大致列出：“这是接下来一周的行程，”
and sometimes even if it's a busy month, she'll be like, this is what's coming up. Yeah, but you can't do that yourself. I kind of do that too. Hashtag relatable. I could do it myself. By the way, you're the call my assistant guy. I never say that.
and sometimes even if it's a busy month, she'll be like, this is what's coming up. Yeah, but you can't do that yourself. I kind of do that too. Hashtag relatable. I could do it myself. By the way, you're the call my assistant guy. I never say that.|||有时候哪怕是个忙碌的月份，她也会说：“这就是接下来的行程。”对，但你自己做不到这一点。我其实也会这样做。#引起共鸣。我自己也能做到。顺便说一句，你就是那个张口闭口“叫我助理”的人。我从来没说过这话。
No, I, where do Wush says that? You do. I make, I look at my own calendar. She'll put stuff on my calendar, but I will give myself a week at a glance. A day at a glance. Talk to the assistants, you say that, I've heard you say it a million times.
No, I, where do Wush says that? You do. I make, I look at my own calendar. She'll put stuff on my calendar, but I will give myself a week at a glance. A day at a glance. Talk to the assistants, you say that, I've heard you say it a million times.|||不，我……Wush在哪儿说过这话？你说过。我让……我会看我自己的日历。她会在我的日历上安排事情，但我会给自己安排一周概览。一天概览。跟助理沟通去吧，你就是这么说的，我听你说过无数次了。
Listen, I love you. There are very few people who love you more than I do. I love you a lot. Thanks, Sean. But you're made up of your nothing but blind spots. Sean, do you have an assistant? Sean laughed at it too. You know what, he loves you too. Do you have an assistant? Sean laughed at it too. Do you have an assistant, Sean?
Listen, I love you. There are very few people who love you more than I do. I love you a lot. Thanks, Sean. But you're made up of your nothing but blind spots. Sean, do you have an assistant? Sean laughed at it too. You know what, he loves you too. Do you have an assistant? Sean laughed at it too. Do you have an assistant, Sean?|||听着，我爱你。世界上没几个人比我更爱你。我非常爱你。谢谢你，肖恩。但你浑身上下全都是盲区。肖恩，你有助理吗？肖恩也笑了。你知道吗，他也爱你。你有助理吗？肖恩也笑了。你有助理吗，肖恩？
I do, yes. It helps my life. Do you not know who his assistant is? Hang on. JB? No, I don't. How do you not? Why do I not? Because I know Liz and I know Bloom. Wait, what's his or her name?
I do, yes. It helps my life. Do you not know who his assistant is? Hang on. JB? No, I don't. How do you not? Why do I not? Because I know Liz and I know Bloom. Wait, what's his or her name?|||我有，是的。这给我的生活带来了很大帮助。你难道不知道他的助理是谁吗？等一下。是JB？不，我不知道。你怎么会不知道？我为什么会不知道？因为我认识莉兹，我也认识布鲁姆。等等，他或她的名字叫什么？
Nick. Why have I never met Nick or ever heard of Nick? Because you're not, this is what I'm saying, because you're living in a blind spot, bro. Hey, Wayne, keep your voice down. I'd love it if your name was Wayne. I know, Wade. Only thing better would be Wade.
Nick. Why have I never met Nick or ever heard of Nick? Because you're not, this is what I'm saying, because you're living in a blind spot, bro. Hey, Wayne, keep your voice down. I'd love it if your name was Wayne. I know, Wade. Only thing better would be Wade.|||尼克。为什么我从来没见过尼克，也从来没听说过尼克？因为你没有——这就是我要说的，因为你活在盲区里，兄弟。嘿，韦恩，小声点。如果你叫韦恩，我可太高兴了。我知道，韦德。唯一更好的名字就是韦德了。
If my name was Wade. I had a buddy named Wade, Wade Wilson. Hi, Wade. Wait, what's been, Sean, how you been doing? Are you okay? Great. I just, I'm still frazzled about that being late. You're frazzled, but how are you in general? Oh, thanks for asking.
If my name was Wade. I had a buddy named Wade, Wade Wilson. Hi, Wade. Wait, what's been, Sean, how you been doing? Are you okay? Great. I just, I'm still frazzled about that being late. You're frazzled, but how are you in general? Oh, thanks for asking.|||如果我叫韦德。我有个哥们儿叫韦德，韦德·威尔逊。嗨，韦德。等等，最近怎么样，肖恩，你最近过得好吗？你没事吧？挺好的。我只是……我还在为刚才迟到这事儿感到心烦意乱。你心烦意乱，但你整体感觉怎么样？哦，谢谢关心。
I'm really good. Are you? Yeah. Why, something I should know? No, I couldn't tell the other night. Like I just, I feel like it's a very, nothing to do with what's going on in the, I don't mean like sort of,
I'm really good. Are you? Yeah. Why, something I should know? No, I couldn't tell the other night. Like I just, I feel like it's a very, nothing to do with what's going on in the, I don't mean like sort of,|||我真的很好。是吗？对。怎么了，有什么我应该知道的事吗？没有，我前天晚上可看不出来。就好像我觉得这非常……跟正在发生的事情毫无关系，我不是指那种……
No. I just mean that like in general, it's a weird time. For me, it's kind of a weird time. I woke up yesterday with, and I don't get this a lot, I had like general anxiety. About? I don't know, I couldn't explain it. Low grade?
No. I just mean that like in general, it's a weird time. For me, it's kind of a weird time. I woke up yesterday with, and I don't get this a lot, I had like general anxiety. About? I don't know, I couldn't explain it. Low grade?|||不。我只是觉得总体来说，这是一个奇怪的时期。对我来说，这是个挺奇怪的时期。我昨天醒来时——我平时很少这样——产生了一种莫名的焦虑。关于什么的？我不知道，我也说不清。低度焦虑？
Yeah, kind of low grade and I couldn't shake it and I don't know and I'm not really made that way in the sense that like, I feel really lucky that, I think I've mentioned this before, Downey once said, nobody wakes up in the morning happier to be themselves than you. And it's sort of true. That's kind of true, yeah.
Yeah, kind of low grade and I couldn't shake it and I don't know and I'm not really made that way in the sense that like, I feel really lucky that, I think I've mentioned this before, Downey once said, nobody wakes up in the morning happier to be themselves than you. And it's sort of true. That's kind of true, yeah.|||对，有点像低度焦虑，而且我怎么都甩不掉这种感觉，我不知道，我本来也不是那种性格的人，就觉得我真的很幸运，我想我以前提到过这个，小罗伯特·唐尼曾经说过：“没有人早上醒来时会比你更庆幸自己能成为自己。”这倒有点符合事实。这确实有点道理，对。
But I do. But you're not bright enough to be concerned about things. I think so, I think that's probably true. It takes a lot of intelligence to really see all the problems that could come your way. I think that's true. Or it's just that everything's worked out. Mm-hmm.
But I do. But you're not bright enough to be concerned about things. I think so, I think that's probably true. It takes a lot of intelligence to really see all the problems that could come your way. I think that's true. Or it's just that everything's worked out. Mm-hmm.|||但我确实如此。但你不够聪明，所以才不会为事情操心。我想是的，这大概是真的。需要有很高的智商，才能真正看清所有可能找上门来的问题。我觉得这是真的。或者只是因为一切都顺风顺水吧。嗯。
But it's one of the two. But we had a wonderful conversation on Saturday around the table, I loved that. We had a really great conversation with our friend Danny Dees, whom we all love and adore. But you know, sometimes, so I think that the contrast when I'm not feeling great is so, is I really feel it because. Usually you're 72 and breezy.
But it's one of the two. But we had a wonderful conversation on Saturday around the table, I loved that. We had a really great conversation with our friend Danny Dees, whom we all love and adore. But you know, sometimes, so I think that the contrast when I'm not feeling great is so, is I really feel it because. Usually you're 72 and breezy.|||总而言之是这两者之一。不过我们在周六围坐在一起进行了一次非常棒的对话，我太喜欢了。我们和我们的朋友丹尼·迪斯（Danny Dees）进行了一次非常棒的对话，我们大家都很爱他、崇拜他。但你知道，有时，所以我认为当我感觉不太好时，这种反差是如此之大，以至于我真的能切身感受到，因为平时你总是72岁还悠闲自在。
Yeah, yeah, and it was weird, man. And I kind of took all day and I was like, and I was just trying to, I don't know, I was looking to redirect all day. I was like, what am I gonna do? What am I gonna do? And how about today? Did you wake up back to it today? Yeah, a little bit better today.
Yeah, yeah, and it was weird, man. And I kind of took all day and I was like, and I was just trying to, I don't know, I was looking to redirect all day. I was like, what am I gonna do? What am I gonna do? And how about today? Did you wake up back to it today? Yeah, a little bit better today.|||对，对，而且那感觉真怪，老兄。我花了一整天的时间，就好像，我一整天都在试图——我不知道，我一整天都在寻找转移注意力的方法。我就想：我该怎么办？我该怎么办？那今天呢？你今天醒来时恢复状态了吗？对，今天好多了。
Little bit better. Can I tell you what it was? Because I had the same thing yesterday. It was the sugar. You think so? It's sugar, I swear to God. Oh, that's interesting. It's fucking, we had that big fat fucking carrot cake
Little bit better. Can I tell you what it was? Because I had the same thing yesterday. It was the sugar. You think so? It's sugar, I swear to God. Oh, that's interesting. It's fucking, we had that big fat fucking carrot cake|||好一点点。我能告诉你那是什么原因吗？因为我昨天也有同感。是糖。你觉得是吗？是糖，我发誓。哦，那挺有意思的。他妈的，我们吃了那个又大又肥的胡萝卜蛋糕。
and God, was it good? And I was a disaster yesterday. Really? But it was Will's cheat day and everybody had a little piece and I was a disaster yesterday. Really? But it was Will's cheat day, and everybody had a little piece of cake. Cheat meal, not day. Cheat meal, cheat meal, sorry. And everybody had served a little piece of cake,
and God, was it good? And I was a disaster yesterday. Really? But it was Will's cheat day and everybody had a little piece and I was a disaster yesterday. Really? But it was Will's cheat day, and everybody had a little piece of cake. Cheat meal, not day. Cheat meal, cheat meal, sorry. And everybody had served a little piece of cake,|||天哪，它有多好吃？我昨天简直一团糟。真的吗？但那是威尔的作弊日，每个人都吃了一小块，我昨天整个人都不好了。真的吗？但那是威尔的作弊日，每个人都吃了一小块蛋糕。是作弊餐，不是作弊日。作弊餐，作弊餐，抱歉。每个人都分到了一小块蛋糕，
and Will got served two pieces of cake and five things of ice cream. And I said, how many people are you cheating for? Exactly. Well, how many people are you cheating on? You did, but did you notice this week that I ate mine, I only had one piece of cake and then I had a few scoops of ice cream, which I brought with me like a psycho.
and Will got served two pieces of cake and five things of ice cream. And I said, how many people are you cheating for? Exactly. Well, how many people are you cheating on? You did, but did you notice this week that I ate mine, I only had one piece of cake and then I had a few scoops of ice cream, which I brought with me like a psycho.|||结果威尔分到了两大块蛋糕和五份冰淇淋。我说：“你这是在替多少人作弊啊？”一点没错。好吧，你这是在对多少人进行感情不忠？你确实这么做了，但你注意到这周我吃我那份的时候了吗，我只吃了一块蛋糕，然后吃了好几勺冰淇淋——那是我像个神经病一样自己带的。
You brought fucking chocolate sauce with you too. No, that was Jen's, that was at her house. This isn't a cheat day, you're impregnating people as well, I guess. It's like, it's not just, you know, heavy padding. But do you remember two weeks ago when Jen, when our friend, when I went to have a second piece and she looked at me and she was like,
You brought fucking chocolate sauce with you too. No, that was Jen's, that was at her house. This isn't a cheat day, you're impregnating people as well, I guess. It's like, it's not just, you know, heavy padding. But do you remember two weeks ago when Jen, when our friend, when I went to have a second piece and she looked at me and she was like,|||你他妈还随身带了巧克力酱。不，那是詹姆斯的，是在她家的时候。这可不是什么作弊日，我猜你这是在到处让人怀孕吧。就好像，这不只是什么沉重的垫衬物。但你还记得两周前，当詹姆斯——我们的朋友——当我准备吃第二块时，她看着我，然后露出一副……
honey, do you really want to do that? She shamed me. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This week. You guys just need to get married and get it over with. I know, this week, she saw me look at her, like she'd had like three tiny bites of her cake and she pushed it towards me. And I thought it was a really kind.
honey, do you really want to do that? She shamed me. Yeah, yeah, yeah. This week. You guys just need to get married and get it over with. I know, this week, she saw me look at her, like she'd had like three tiny bites of her cake and she pushed it towards me. And I thought it was a really kind.|||“亲爱的，你真的要这么做吗？”的表情？她羞辱了我。对，对，对。这星期。你们俩干脆结婚算了吧，也省得费事。我知道，这周，她看到我看着她——当时她只咬了她那块蛋糕的三小口，然后她就把蛋糕推向了我。我觉得这真的挺体贴的……
I saw that. And then I kind of got sad. I was like, why didn't she push it towards me? Because you don't look as much like a trash can. A little bit. I think that, Shawnee, this is my vision of you, is that you're like, I'm only having one piece and then you kept going into the kitchen and you would stuff.
I saw that. And then I kind of got sad. I was like, why didn't she push it towards me? Because you don't look as much like a trash can. A little bit. I think that, Shawnee, this is my vision of you, is that you're like, I'm only having one piece and then you kept going into the kitchen and you would stuff.|||我看到了。然后我莫名有点难过。我就想：她怎么不把蛋糕推给我呢？因为你看上去不那么像个垃圾桶。稍微有点像。我觉得，肖尼，你在我心里的形象就是那种：“我只吃一块，”然后你就不停地走进厨房去大吃大喝。
That is correct. And silence and shame, yeah. That is correct. Stuff. And silence and shame, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Anyway, so we're feeling good today though, right? We're all back to it. That's interesting about the sugar thing though, Jay. I want to talk about that.
That is correct. And silence and shame, yeah. That is correct. Stuff. And silence and shame, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Anyway, so we're feeling good today though, right? We're all back to it. That's interesting about the sugar thing though, Jay. I want to talk about that.|||完全正确。伴随着沉默与羞耻感，是的。完全正确。胡吃海塞。伴随着沉默与羞耻感，是的。对，对。不管怎样，不过我们今天感觉挺好吧？大家都恢复状态了。不过关于糖的那件事挺有意思的，杰。我想聊聊这个。
I swear to God. I think the sugar thing is good, and you know what the other thing is? My new hack, and maybe I've talked about this, I just, I tried to call a few people and talk to a few people and ask them how they were doing, and that was really helpful. Oh, that's they were doing, and that was really helpful. Oh, that's good.
I swear to God. I think the sugar thing is good, and you know what the other thing is? My new hack, and maybe I've talked about this, I just, I tried to call a few people and talk to a few people and ask them how they were doing, and that was really helpful. Oh, that's they were doing, and that was really helpful. Oh, that's good.|||我向上帝发誓。我觉得糖的那种说法挺准的，而且你知道另一件事是什么吗？我的新绝招——也许我谈到过这个——我只是，我试着给几个人打电话，和几个人聊聊，问问他们最近过得怎么样，这真的很有帮助。哦，那是他们最近过得怎么样，这真的很有帮助。哦，那挺好的。
Yeah, that really, really helped. And get out of your own head a little bit. Do you not have my right number? You might not have my right number. I knew how you were doing, okay? Which I just seen you nine hours before. We all know how you were doing, okay? I'm cold this morning.
Yeah, that really, really helped. And get out of your own head a little bit. Do you not have my right number? You might not have my right number. I knew how you were doing, okay? Which I just seen you nine hours before. We all know how you were doing, okay? I'm cold this morning.|||对，这真的真的很有帮助。而且能让你稍微从自己的世界里跳出来一点。你是不是没有我的正确号码？你可能没有我的正确号码。我知道你过得怎么样，行了吧？我九个小时前才刚见过你。我们都知道你过得怎么样，好吧？我今天早上觉得有点冷。
It's chilly in LA. We love you. We love you. You got the hoodie on. I love you and I love our next guest guys today We have a fella who's been a part of our lives for a long time He's been delivering films and TV shows as a director and as an actor for about 35 years He's a huge part of the entertainment business, but keeps well out of the spotlight as a director He can deliver some of the most hilarious moments on screen or the most brutal and disturbing. As an actor, he can do the same.
It's chilly in LA. We love you. We love you. You got the hoodie on. I love you and I love our next guest guys today We have a fella who's been a part of our lives for a long time He's been delivering films and TV shows as a director and as an actor for about 35 years He's a huge part of the entertainment business, but keeps well out of the spotlight as a director He can deliver some of the most hilarious moments on screen or the most brutal and disturbing. As an actor, he can do the same.|||洛杉矶有点凉。我们爱你。我们爱你。你穿着连帽衫呢。我爱你，我也爱我们的下一位嘉宾，伙计们，今天我们迎来了一位陪伴了我们很长时间的老朋友，他作为导演和演员从事电影和电视剧创作大约有35年了。他是娱乐界的重要人物，但在担任导演时却刻意远离聚光灯。作为导演，他能在银幕上呈现出最搞笑的时刻，也能呈现出最残酷、最令人不安的时刻。作为演员，他同样能做到这一点。
He loves football, his son, and Ari Emanuel. Not necessarily in that order. I love him, his movies, and his ability to send hilarious gifts in that order. Folks, it's America's Pete Berg. Come on out, Pete. Wow! Ah!
He loves football, his son, and Ari Emanuel. Not necessarily in that order. I love him, his movies, and his ability to send hilarious gifts in that order. Folks, it's America's Pete Berg. Come on out, Pete. Wow! Ah!|||他热爱橄榄球、他的儿子以及阿里·伊曼纽尔（Ari Emanuel）。排名不分先后。我爱他、他的电影，以及他发送搞笑礼物的能力——按这个顺序。各位，这就是全美瞩目的皮特·伯格。出来吧，皮特。哇！啊！
Wowie, wowie. Woo! Did I get that right? Is that the order? Is your love for football, Emmett and Ari, is that the right order? It's my son. Fletch weights.
Wowie, wowie. Woo! Did I get that right? Is that the order? Is your love for football, Emmett and Ari, is that the right order? It's my son. Fletch weights.|||哇塞，哇塞。呜！我没说错吧？是这个顺序吗？你对橄榄球、埃米特（Emmett）和阿里的爱，是这个顺序吗？是我儿子。Fletch weights（哑铃品牌/或人名谐音）。
It's my son Ari football, I would have to say. But they're all up there, dude. They're all up there. That's cool, it's so nice to meet you. It's a pleasure to meet you. Well, sorry to hear about the anxiety. I agree with Bateman. It's definitely, the sugar's not helping, so.
It's my son Ari football, I would have to say. But they're all up there, dude. They're all up there. That's cool, it's so nice to meet you. It's a pleasure to meet you. Well, sorry to hear about the anxiety. I agree with Bateman. It's definitely, the sugar's not helping, so.|||我必须说，顺序是我儿子、阿里、橄榄球。但他们都在很高的位置，老兄。都在很高的位置。太酷了，很高兴认识你。很高兴认识你。嗯，听说你焦虑，我深表遗憾。我同意贝特曼的看法。绝对是的，糖分对此毫无帮助，所以。
No. And you're very smart about that stuff, right? Pete, you should know I've been off the sugar for a few months, but I have one cheat meal every seven days as per my. That's why it's affecting you a lot. Yeah, probably. Because your body's so cleaned out.
No. And you're very smart about that stuff, right? Pete, you should know I've been off the sugar for a few months, but I have one cheat meal every seven days as per my. That's why it's affecting you a lot. Yeah, probably. Because your body's so cleaned out.|||不。而且你对那种事很有研究，对吧？皮特，你应该知道我戒糖已经几个月了，但我每七天会吃一顿作弊餐，按照我的……难怪它对你的影响这么大。对，可能吧。因为你的身体已经被彻底清理干净了。
But does sugar have to be part of the cheat meal? Can't you just eat pizza or something like- Bacon. Yeah, have bacon. I think it's that and everything else. I probably should. I think that it's just- Well, but like any of us sort of folks in recovery,
But does sugar have to be part of the cheat meal? Can't you just eat pizza or something like- Bacon. Yeah, have bacon. I think it's that and everything else. I probably should. I think that it's just- Well, but like any of us sort of folks in recovery,|||但糖必须是作弊餐的一部分吗？难道你就不能只吃披萨或者诸如此类的东西吗——培根。对，吃培根。我觉得是糖以及其他所有东西共同导致的。我大概应该这么做。我觉得这只是——好吧，但就像我们这群处于恢复期的任何人一样，
we miss the sweet. We miss the sugar of alcohol, and I think it's, for a long time, for some reason cigarettes curved that, curved it for me for a while, and then when that went away, like, yeah, then the Coke, because it looks like sugar. Stevia helps me out. Stevia helps me out. Pete, you're good with, you're good with, look at you, God.
we miss the sweet. We miss the sugar of alcohol, and I think it's, for a long time, for some reason cigarettes curved that, curved it for me for a while, and then when that went away, like, yeah, then the Coke, because it looks like sugar. Stevia helps me out. Stevia helps me out. Pete, you're good with, you're good with, look at you, God.|||我们怀念甜味。我们怀念酒精带来的那种“糖分”，我觉得长期以来，出于某种原因，香烟抑制了这种渴望，有一段时间为我克制住了这种渴望，然后当烟戒掉之后，对，然后就是可乐，因为它看起来像糖。甜菊糖帮了我大忙。甜菊糖帮了我大忙。皮特，你很擅长……你很擅长……看看你，天哪。
You look trim, man. You look great, Pete. You always look so good. If you took that tarp off right now, you'd see someone that could beat your ass, Arnett. Pretty handling. I know he could. I would never.
You look trim, man. You look great, Pete. You always look so good. If you took that tarp off right now, you'd see someone that could beat your ass, Arnett. Pretty handling. I know he could. I would never.|||你看上去线条很匀称，老兄。你看起来状态真好，皮特。你总是看起来这么棒。如果你现在把那块帆布扯下来，你就会看到一个能把你揍得落花流水的人，阿奈特。处理得很漂亮。我知道他能。我才不会。
Runs a boxing gym. I do. I've known Pete, Pete, you and I have known each other very loosely for years. I've said hi to you many times, and I wish it was more than just a hi, it's always been in passing. And Sean, I don't believe we've met,
Runs a boxing gym. I do. I've known Pete, Pete, you and I have known each other very loosely for years. I've said hi to you many times, and I wish it was more than just a hi, it's always been in passing. And Sean, I don't believe we've met,|||经营着一家拳击馆。我确实在经营。我认识皮特——皮特，咱俩泛泛之交好多年了。我对你打过无数次招呼，我希望不仅仅只是打招呼，我们以前总是在擦肩而过时寒暄。还有肖恩，我想我们以前没见过面吧，
but it's a pleasure to meet you also. This is correct, we have not met, and it is a pleasure to meet you too, Peter. I'm a big fan. Pete, tell me about the boxing while we're here. It's been a steady escalation of commitment from you, not just in training, but then like now you're co-owning a gym. Yeah, so about 15 years ago,
but it's a pleasure to meet you also. This is correct, we have not met, and it is a pleasure to meet you too, Peter. I'm a big fan. Pete, tell me about the boxing while we're here. It's been a steady escalation of commitment from you, not just in training, but then like now you're co-owning a gym. Yeah, so about 15 years ago,|||但认识你我也很高兴。没错，我们确实没见过面，很高兴认识你，彼得。我是你的超级粉丝趁我们在这儿，皮特，跟我讲讲拳击的事吧。你对这件事的投入一直在稳步升级，不仅是训练，而且现在你还联合拥有了一家拳击馆。对，大概15年前，
I was thinking about maybe a side hobby, and people were asking me if I wanted to go in on a restaurant or maybe a bar, and to me that just seemed like a horrible idea for many reasons. Just like, talk about all blindspot. I had enough of, because I'm like you, I have a lot of blindspots, but I sensed that
I was thinking about maybe a side hobby, and people were asking me if I wanted to go in on a restaurant or maybe a bar, and to me that just seemed like a horrible idea for many reasons. Just like, talk about all blindspot. I had enough of, because I'm like you, I have a lot of blindspots, but I sensed that|||我在考虑搞个业余爱好，当时有人问我想不想合伙开家餐厅或者酒吧，对我来说，出于种种原因，这简直是个糟糕透顶的主意。就像——谈谈所有的盲区吧。我受够了……因为我和你一样，有很多盲区，但我隐约感觉，
that would be a bad move for me to open a bar, be part of that. And at the time, I was boxing at a club that Bob Dylan owns in Santa Monica. And the trainer of the gym got into a beef with Bob, which is a whole great story in itself. Getting into beefs with Bob Dylan, which like there's a whole side of Bob Dylan around a boxing gym. Hey, he'll hit you with a guitar.
that would be a bad move for me to open a bar, be part of that. And at the time, I was boxing at a club that Bob Dylan owns in Santa Monica. And the trainer of the gym got into a beef with Bob, which is a whole great story in itself. Getting into beefs with Bob Dylan, which like there's a whole side of Bob Dylan around a boxing gym. Hey, he'll hit you with a guitar.|||开酒吧、参与那种生意对当时的我是个烂主意。当时，我在圣莫尼卡一家鲍勃·迪伦（Bob Dylan）名下的俱乐部练习拳击。那家拳击馆的教练跟鲍勃闹翻了，这本身就是一个非常精彩的故事。跟鲍勃·迪伦闹翻，就好像在拳击馆周围还隐藏着鲍勃·迪伦的另一面。嘿，他会用吉他砸你的。
You know, you're really annoying me today. If you don't do something, I'm going to get physical on you. But we used to spar Bob, but you could never hit. You weren't really allowed to hit him back. And he would pop you. Bob Dylan had a sharp jab. It was supposed to be like, but you couldn't hit him back. So I took a few shots from Bob. But Dylan got in a fight with the then head trainer
You know, you're really annoying me today. If you don't do something, I'm going to get physical on you. But we used to spar Bob, but you could never hit. You weren't really allowed to hit him back. And he would pop you. Bob Dylan had a sharp jab. It was supposed to be like, but you couldn't hit him back. So I took a few shots from Bob. But Dylan got in a fight with the then head trainer|||你知道吗，你今天真的很烦人。如果你再不识相点，我要对你不客气了。但我们以前经常和鲍勃进行实战对练，不过你永远不能还手。你其实不允许还击他。而且他会冷不防给你一拳。鲍勃·迪伦的直拳很犀利。本该是那种切磋，但你不能还手。所以我挨了鲍勃几拳。但迪伦跟当时的主教练打了一架，
and fired him, and Gary Shanling, who's a good friend of mine, was also training at that gym. And Gary came to me and said, Pete, why don't we take this trainer and start our own gym? And I said, okay. Seemed like a better, more interesting experience than opening a bar. And so Gary and I backed this gentleman,
and fired him, and Gary Shanling, who's a good friend of mine, was also training at that gym. And Gary came to me and said, Pete, why don't we take this trainer and start our own gym? And I said, okay. Seemed like a better, more interesting experience than opening a bar. And so Gary and I backed this gentleman,|||并把教练解雇了。加里·尚林（Gary Shanling），我的好朋友，当时也在那家拳击馆训练。加里来找我说：“皮特，我们为什么不带着这个教练自己开一家拳击馆呢？”我说：“好啊。”这似乎比开酒吧是个更好、更有趣的经历。于是加里和我资助了这位先生，
started our own gym, and the gentleman who we hired ended up leaving, we had some problems with him, and then Gary died, RIP Gary Shanling, who I love so much, and left me alone with the boxing gym. And it has been one of the stupidest things that I have ever done in my life. Barf fucking none. Wait, why?
started our own gym, and the gentleman who we hired ended up leaving, we had some problems with him, and then Gary died, RIP Gary Shanling, who I love so much, and left me alone with the boxing gym. And it has been one of the stupidest things that I have ever done in my life. Barf fucking none. Wait, why?|||开办了我们自己的拳击馆，而我们雇佣的那位先生最后还是离开了，我们和他之间出了一些问题，然后加里去世了——愿我深爱的加里·尚林安息，只留我一个人独自面对这家拳击馆。这绝对是我这辈子做过的最愚蠢的事情之一。他妈的没有之一。等等，为什么？
What's the next? Do not open up. That sounds like such an easy thing to run. Low overhead, there's no maintenance, there's no. Clean these towels and lock the door. Two things, actually, technically three things. One thing is people say that I got a lot of blind spots, but I don't see them.
What's the next? Do not open up. That sounds like such an easy thing to run. Low overhead, there's no maintenance, there's no. Clean these towels and lock the door. Two things, actually, technically three things. One thing is people say that I got a lot of blind spots, but I don't see them.|||接下来是什么？千万别开。听起来这似乎是件很好经营的事。运营成本低，没有维护成本，也没有……洗洗毛巾然后锁上门就行。实际上有两件事，严格来说是三件事。第一件事是，人们说我有很多盲区，但我自己看不见。
The other thing is this, Pete, is my son who's 16, the last year and a half, he's gotten into boxing and he's boxing at another gym that I'm not gonna name, but he's going twice. And now he just said to me last night, dad, can I start going three times a week? And he boxes with this guy, which is really cool. And I was thinking like, I'd love to get him out to your gym maybe
The other thing is this, Pete, is my son who's 16, the last year and a half, he's gotten into boxing and he's boxing at another gym that I'm not gonna name, but he's going twice. And now he just said to me last night, dad, can I start going three times a week? And he boxes with this guy, which is really cool. And I was thinking like, I'd love to get him out to your gym maybe|||另一件事是这样的，皮特，我儿子今年16岁，在过去的一年半里，他迷上了拳击，他现在在另一家我不会点名的拳击馆练习，他每周去两次。现在他昨晚刚对我说：“爸爸，我能一周去三次吗？”他跟着这个人练习拳击，这真的很酷。我在想，我很乐意带他去你的拳击馆看看，
and get him in there and get another. Church Hill Boxing Club in Santa Monica, come on down. It's a great gym. Great, well, we're gonna get a nice boon. But here's what I wanted to say is a little sideline because I do want to finish the boxing theme is, we haven't spent enough time, I feel like we've been delinquent on this podcast,
and get him in there and get another. Church Hill Boxing Club in Santa Monica, come on down. It's a great gym. Great, well, we're gonna get a nice boon. But here's what I wanted to say is a little sideline because I do want to finish the boxing theme is, we haven't spent enough time, I feel like we've been delinquent on this podcast,|||让他去那儿体验一下，再去另一家……圣莫尼卡的丘吉尔拳击俱乐部（Church Hill Boxing Club），欢迎光临。那是个很棒的拳击馆。太棒了，我们会有个好彩头的。但我想说的是一个题外话，因为我想把拳击这个话题收个尾，那就是我们没有花足够的时间——我觉得我们在这次播客中做得不够称职——
we haven't spent enough time talking about and giving credence to Gary Shanley. Because he was one of, talk about a heavyweight to use the analogy. This guy was an unbelievable, he's the reason I got HBO. Because Pete, you knew him, I didn't know the guy,
we haven't spent enough time talking about and giving credence to Gary Shanley. Because he was one of, talk about a heavyweight to use the analogy. This guy was an unbelievable, he's the reason I got HBO. Because Pete, you knew him, I didn't know the guy,|||我们没有花足够的时间来谈论加里·尚利（Gary Shanley）并给予他应有的赞誉。因为他绝对是——用拳击的类比来说——一个重量级人物。这家伙简直难以置信，他是我当年安装HBO的原因。因为皮特，你认识他，我不认识这家伙，
but what an influence he had on what we consider to be comedy now, in a lot of ways. Gary Shandling, fuck. Actors, writers, format, show us. What was he like? What was he like? So, I mean, I got to see both sides of Gary. I saw him as a comic titan,
but what an influence he had on what we consider to be comedy now, in a lot of ways. Gary Shanling, fuck. Actors, writers, format, show us. What was he like? What was he like? So, I mean, I got to see both sides of Gary. I saw him as a comic titan,|||但在很多方面，他对我们现在所认为的“喜剧”产生了多么巨大的影响啊。加里·尚林，靠。演员、编剧、节目形式，向我们展示了。他是个什么样的人？他是个什么样的人？所以，我的意思是，我有幸看到了加里的两面。我看到他作为喜剧巨人的那一面，
and a very entrenched member of our industry. And that's how most people knew Gary. The boxing gym is actually a fascinating culture. Our gym is meant to be a pretty traditional boxing gym with pro fighters. So we would have a lot of Russians, South Americans. We had folks from Japan. we had Chinese fighters, and these were young men who would come to LA, rarely spoke much English, were not at all connected, and Gary took a deep interest in their lives. And I would come into the gym, and Gary would be sitting
and a very entrenched member of our industry. And that's how most people knew Gary. The boxing gym is actually a fascinating culture. Our gym is meant to be a pretty traditional boxing gym with pro fighters. So we would have a lot of Russians, South Americans. We had folks from Japan. we had Chinese fighters, and these were young men who would come to LA, rarely spoke much English, were not at all connected, and Gary took a deep interest in their lives. And I would come into the gym, and Gary would be sitting|||以及作为我们行业中根深蒂固的一员的那一面。这也是大多数人认识加里的方式。拳击馆其实是一种引人入胜的文化。我们的拳击馆旨在成为一家拥有职业拳手的传统拳击馆。所以我们会有很多俄罗斯人、南美洲人。我们有来自日本的人。我们还有中国拳手，这些都是来到洛杉矶的年轻小伙子，英语说得很少，与外界毫无联系，而加里对他们的生活产生了浓厚的兴趣。我走进拳击馆时，总会看到加里坐在那儿，
with a couple of kids from Argentina, talking about boxing and talking about life, and had this incredible connection and when Gary passed away there was a huge memorial. I don't know if any of you guys went to it, you know, a couple thousand people, you know, everyone in Hollywood went to Gary's memorial service and then the next day we had a service for him at the gym and there were a couple of hundred people who knew Gary only as G from the gym. And they had no idea that he was famous,
with a couple of kids from Argentina, talking about boxing and talking about life, and had this incredible connection and when Gary passed away there was a huge memorial. I don't know if any of you guys went to it, you know, a couple thousand people, you know, everyone in Hollywood went to Gary's memorial service and then the next day we had a service for him at the gym and there were a couple of hundred people who knew Gary only as G from the gym. And they had no idea that he was famous,|||和几个来自阿根廷的孩子一起，谈论拳击，谈论生活，他们之间有着这种不可思议的联系。而当加里去世时，举办了一场盛大的追悼会。我不知道你们当中有没有人去过，你知道的，有几千人，你知道的，好莱坞的所有人都去参加了加里的追悼会，然后第二天我们在拳击馆为他举行了一场追悼仪式，现场有几百人，他们只知道加里是拳击馆里的“G”。他们根本不知道他很有名，
they had no idea that he had this other life. They just thought he was a really sweet guy who cared about them. And he really did. And so that was a side of Gary. He absolutely loved boxing. He loved Bob Dylan and loved fighting with Bob Dylan. I'd love to see that pay-per-view.
they had no idea that he had this other life. They just thought he was a really sweet guy who cared about them. And he really did. And so that was a side of Gary. He absolutely loved boxing. He loved Bob Dylan and loved fighting with Bob Dylan. I'd love to see that pay-per-view.|||他们根本不知道他还有这样另一面人生。他们只觉得他是个真正温柔、关心他们的好人。而他确实如此。所以这是加里的一面。他绝对热爱拳击。他热爱鲍勃·迪伦，也热爱和鲍勃·迪伦打架。我真想看看那个付费点播节目。
That's such a funny image. Gary tried to do a talk show where he would fight you three rounds in the ring, and as soon as those three rounds were over, you would collapse and he'd do an interview. He would do the interview after you'd been punching the shit out of each other, and he only did one with Alec Baldwin.
That's such a funny image. Gary tried to do a talk show where he would fight you three rounds in the ring, and as soon as those three rounds were over, you would collapse and he'd do an interview. He would do the interview after you'd been punching the shit out of each other, and he only did one with Alec Baldwin.|||那画面太搞笑了。加里曾试图做一个脱口秀节目，在节目里他会在擂台上跟你打满三个回合，一旦这三个回合结束，你就会瘫倒在地，然后他就会开始进行采访。他会在你们俩把对方打得半死之后再进行采访，而且他只对亚历克·鲍德温（Alec Baldwin）做过一次这样的采访。
And I was there for it, and they both, I think, had heart attacks, literally mini heart attacks. And at the end of the third round, Baldwin was laying on his side and Gary was laying on his stomach and they were wheezing, there was like. And Gary was trying to ask him questions. How'd you get started Alec?
And I was there for it, and they both, I think, had heart attacks, literally mini heart attacks. And at the end of the third round, Baldwin was laying on his side and Gary was laying on his stomach and they were wheezing, there was like. And Gary was trying to ask him questions. How'd you get started Alec?|||当时我在现场，我觉得他们俩当时都心脏病发作了，真的是轻度心脏病发作。在第三回合结束时，鲍德温侧躺着，加里趴着，他们俩都在呼哧呼哧地喘气，现场大概就是这样。而加里还试图问他问题：“亚历克，你是怎么开始演艺生涯的？”
Yeah, and Baldwin was just like, I think I really need some water. And I'm like, guys, Alec. Yeah, and Baldwin was just like, I think I really need some water. Or something. And I'm like, guys, you're both. Did we see this? You're both, it never aired. Did you shoot it? We did.
Yeah, and Baldwin was just like, I think I really need some water. And I'm like, guys, Alec. Yeah, and Baldwin was just like, I think I really need some water. Or something. And I'm like, guys, you're both. Did we see this? You're both, it never aired. Did you shoot it? We did.|||对，而鲍德温当时的状态就是：“我觉得我真的需要来点水。”我就想：伙计们，亚历克。对，而鲍德温当时的状态就是：“我觉得我真的需要来点水。”或者类似的话。我就想：伙计们，你们俩……我们看过这个吗？你们俩……这段从未播出于世。你们当时拍下来了吗？拍了。
I've seen it, and it got kind of real too when they were fighting too, right? They were beating the shit out of each other. Baldwin was tough, and Gary was deceptively effective as a boxer, and I think Alec didn't quite know was deceptively effective as a boxer. And I think Alec didn't quite know what he was in for. So it started and Alec thought it was going to be kind of fun. And Shanley just started face punching him
I've seen it, and it got kind of real too when they were fighting too, right? They were beating the shit out of each other. Baldwin was tough, and Gary was deceptively effective as a boxer, and I think Alec didn't quite know was deceptively effective as a boxer. And I think Alec didn't quite know what he was in for. So it started and Alec thought it was going to be kind of fun. And Shanley just started face punching him|||我看过，而且他们打架的时候也有点动真格的，对吧？他们把对方往死里揍。鲍德温很抗打，而加里作为拳击手展现出了出人意料的杀伤力，我觉得亚历克赛前并不知道加里作为拳击手竟然这么有杀伤力。我想亚历克根本不知道自己将要面对的是什么。于是比赛开始了，亚历克本以为这会挺好玩的。结果尚林直接开始照着他的脸一拳接一拳地猛砸——
over and over and over. Yeah, it got weirdly real and it was uncomfortable. Pete, you got to show us this. You shot it? Gary shot it, so we could maybe dig it up, but it was priceless, but I was literally concerned that they were both having heart attacks and I got them to stop and drink water
over and over and over. Yeah, it got weirdly real and it was uncomfortable. Pete, you got to show us this. You shot it? Gary shot it, so we could maybe dig it up, but it was priceless, but I was literally concerned that they were both having heart attacks and I got them to stop and drink water|||一遍又一遍，没完没了。对，这变得诡异地真实，让人感到很不舒服。皮特，你得把这个给我们看看。你们拍下来了？是加里拍的，所以我们或许能把它找出来。但这绝对是无价之宝，我当时真的担心他们俩都会心脏病发作，于是我让他们停下来喝水，
and then it was one of those, it was a deep level of exhaustion that just wasn't going away. It's just like an icebreaker before an interview? Yeah, just to put everybody at ease. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Pete, I do want to go back though.
and then it was one of those, it was a deep level of exhaustion that just wasn't going away. It's just like an icebreaker before an interview? Yeah, just to put everybody at ease. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Pete, I do want to go back though.|||然后那种极度的疲惫感就挥之不去。这就像是采访前的破冰环节吗？对，只是为了让每个人都放松下来。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。不过皮特，我确实想把话题转回去。
I want to get back into how you became who you are, which is, as Jason said in the intro, I mean, you're an incredible filmmaker and actor, and you haven't acted as much in the last few years as you used to, but you started as an actor. And Jason, you probably feel a lot of connection to what Pete does because he was able to kind of go from an actor who was in a lot of stuff
I want to get back into how you became who you are, which is, as Jason said in the intro, I mean, you're an incredible filmmaker and actor, and you haven't acted as much in the last few years as you used to, but you started as an actor. And Jason, you probably feel a lot of connection to what Pete does because he was able to kind of go from an actor who was in a lot of stuff|||我想回到你是如何成为今天的你的这个话题上，正如杰森在开场白中所说的那样，你是一位杰出的电影人和演员，虽然这几年你演戏不如以前那么频繁了，但你最初是以演员身份出道的。杰森，你大概对皮特所做的事深有共鸣，因为他能够从一个参演过大量作品的演员……
and people wanted him to become a director yourself, which I know is a trajectory that you're sort of on. Pete, talk a little bit about that, like about being an actor who's auditioning for jobs, then an actor who's in demand, and then turning that into, or having the vision, or having, talk about what it was that inspired you to become a director, et cetera.
and people wanted him to become a director yourself, which I know is a trajectory that you're sort of on. Pete, talk a little bit about that, like about being an actor who's auditioning for jobs, then an actor who's in demand, and then turning that into, or having the vision, or having, talk about what it was that inspired you to become a director, et cetera.|||并且深受人们喜爱的演员，转型成为一名导演，我知道这也是你目前正在走的职业轨迹。皮特，稍微聊聊这个吧，比如作为一个四处试镜找工作的演员，然后成为一个炙手可热的演员，再将这种身份转化为——或者说拥有这种远见，或者拥有……聊聊是什么激发了你成为一名导演的灵感，诸如此类。
So I think one of the light bulb moments for me that got me really starting to think about directing, which is something I'd always thought about, and I think Jason always had too, and it was something we used to talk about when we were working together. I remember on the set of Hancock in particular, you talking about filmmaking and me kind of sensing
So I think one of the light bulb moments for me that got me really starting to think about directing, which is something I'd always thought about, and I think Jason always had too, and it was something we used to talk about when we were working together. I remember on the set of Hancock in particular, you talking about filmmaking and me kind of sensing|||所以我想，对我来说，让我真正开始认真思考导演工作的“灵光一闪”的时刻——这其实是我一直都在考虑的事，我想杰森也一直如此，这是我们以前一起工作时经常谈论的话题。我记得特别是在《全民超人汉考克》（Hancock）的片场，你谈论电影制作，而我当时隐约感觉到……
that you were going to move in this direction. But for me, I was an actor on Chicago Hope, which was a pretty successful medical drama, and we went up against ER every Thursday night at 10 o'clock, and they beat us every Thursday night. But we were still getting 23 million people watching us, which we thought was just horrible, because we were coming in second, and that was horrible,
that you were going to move in this direction. But for me, I was an actor on Chicago Hope, which was a pretty successful medical drama, and we went up against ER every Thursday night at 10 o'clock, and they beat us every Thursday night. But we were still getting 23 million people watching us, which we thought was just horrible, because we were coming in second, and that was horrible,|||你将朝着这个方向发展。但对我来说，当时我是《芝加哥希望》（Chicago Hope）的一名演员，这是一部相当成功的医疗剧，我们每周四晚上10点跟《急诊室的故事》（ER）正面交锋，而他们每周四晚上都把我们打败。但我们依然拥有2300万的收视观众，我们当时觉得这简直糟透了，因为我们只排在第二名，这太糟糕了，
but looking back on it, obviously it wasn't. But I was getting kind of famous as this doctor, Dr. Billy Cronk on Chicago Hope, and you know, thank you. And when you back then in particular got TV famous, you were pretty famous, so wherever I went, people were like, hey Billy, how you doing Billy? How's Diane, my wife on the show. Hey Billy, how's the, and I'm like,
but looking back on it, obviously it wasn't. But I was getting kind of famous as this doctor, Dr. Billy Cronk on Chicago Hope, and you know, thank you. And when you back then in particular got TV famous, you were pretty famous, so wherever I went, people were like, hey Billy, how you doing Billy? How's Diane, my wife on the show. Hey Billy, how's the, and I'm like,|||但现在回想起来，显然并非如此。不过我因为扮演这个医生——《芝加哥希望》里的比利·克朗克（Billy Cronk）医生——而变得有点名气，你知道的，谢谢大家。尤其是当你当年因电视节目而走红时，你是相当红的，所以我无论走到哪里，人们都会说：“嘿，比利，最近怎么样啊，比利？我在剧中的妻子黛安怎么样了？嘿，比利，那个……”而我的反应是：
okay I'm not fucking Billy, my name's Pete. And at a certain point I started sensing that if I wasn't careful, my legacy was going to be Dr. Billy Cronk, the TV doctor. And I was on a plane flying from LA to JFK and I was sitting in my seat and people were walking by me and a man stopped and he said, hey Billy. And I said, my name's not Billy.
okay I'm not fucking Billy, my name's Pete. And at a certain point I started sensing that if I wasn't careful, my legacy was going to be Dr. Billy Cronk, the TV doctor. And I was on a plane flying from LA to JFK and I was sitting in my seat and people were walking by me and a man stopped and he said, hey Billy. And I said, my name's not Billy.|||好吧，我他妈才不是比利，我叫皮特。在某个时刻，我开始隐约感觉到，如果我不加小心，我留在世上的名声将会是“比利·克朗克医生”——那个电视里的医生。当时我正坐在一架从洛杉矶飞往肯尼迪国际机场（JFK）的飞机上，我坐在座位上，人们从我身边走过，一个男人停下来说：“嘿，比利。”我说：“我叫不比利。”
He goes, hey Billy, my wife has this rash, what do you think, show him the rash. And she pulled up her shirt and stuck her elbow which had a really bad rash on it, in my face. And I'm just sitting there staring at this rash, and they're smiling at me. And other people on the planet are all kind of like, hey Billy, what do you think the rash is?
He goes, hey Billy, my wife has this rash, what do you think, show him the rash. And she pulled up her shirt and stuck her elbow which had a really bad rash on it, in my face. And I'm just sitting there staring at this rash, and they're smiling at me. And other people on the planet are all kind of like, hey Billy, what do you think the rash is?|||他接着说：“嘿，比利，我妻子身上长了这种皮疹，你觉得是什么情况，快给他看看这个皮疹。”然后她掀起衬衫，把长了严重皮疹的手肘怼到了我脸上。而我当时就坐在那儿死死盯着这个皮疹，他们却在对我和善地微笑。地球上的其他人也全都一副……“嘿，比利，你觉得这皮疹是什么情况？”的态度。
And I'm like, that's it, I'm not doing this anymore. And I started writing, and I wrote a movie, Very Bad Things, which was my first film. And that was something that once I got a taste of that and figured out that I could do it, I never really looked back. And I do love acting, but I was not gonna be Billy Cronk for the rest of my career.
And I'm like, that's it, I'm not doing this anymore. And I started writing, and I wrote a movie, Very Bad Things, which was my first film. And that was something that once I got a taste of that and figured out that I could do it, I never really looked back. And I do love acting, but I was not gonna be Billy Cronk for the rest of my career.|||我就想：够了，我再也不干这行了。于是我开始写作，我写了一部电影《坏坏 S 档案》（Very Bad Things），这是我的第一部电影。一旦我尝到了那种甜头并意识到自己能做到这一点之后，我就再也没有真正回头看。我确实热爱表演，但我绝不会在职业生涯剩下的时间里一直扮演比利·克朗克。
But what was that thing that made, were you scared to be like, I can't believe I'm gonna try to be Billy Crunk for the rest of my career. But what was that thing that made you, were you scared to be like, I can't believe I'm going to try to do this. Like, how did you get over the fear of- Because you had a real career as an actor. Like, you see, you got to make a leap a little bit and go like, all right, I'm going to do this. So I was flying to New York to act when the rash-
But what was that thing that made, were you scared to be like, I can't believe I'm gonna try to be Billy Crunk for the rest of my career. But what was that thing that made you, were you scared to be like, I can't believe I'm going to try to do this. Like, how did you get over the fear of- Because you had a real career as an actor. Like, you see, you got to make a leap a little bit and go like, all right, I'm going to do this. So I was flying to New York to act when the rash-|||但究竟是什么让你……你当时会不会害怕得想：“我简直不敢相信我要一辈子尝试去当比利·克朗克。”但究竟是什么让你……你当时会不会害怕得想：“我简直不敢相信我要尝试去干这个。”比如，你是如何克服那种对……因为你当时作为一个演员已经有了真正的事业。比如，你看，你必须实现某种跨越，然后说：“好吧，我要豁出去了。”所以我当时正飞往纽约去演戏，就在长了皮疹那件事发生时——
The same guy was on the plane and said, I have a different rash. And the reason I was on that plane and said, I have a different rash. And the reason I was on that plane where I was presented with the rash was I was flying to New York to be in a movie called Cop Land. I was going to act in it. And that was Stallone and De Niro
The same guy was on the plane and said, I have a different rash. And the reason I was on that plane and said, I have a different rash. And the reason I was on that plane where I was presented with the rash was I was flying to New York to be in a movie called Cop Land. I was going to act in it. And that was Stallone and De Niro|||同一个家伙也在飞机上，并且说：“我身上长了另一种皮疹。”我之所以在那架飞机上被展示那种皮疹，原因是我当时正飞往纽约去参演一部名为《警察帝国》（Cop Land）的电影。我将要在里面演个角色。那是史泰龙和罗伯特·德尼罗主演的电影，
and Stallone had put weight on and was going to try and win an Oscar. And this was Harvey Weinstein producing it in the height of his power and Ray Liotta and Harvey Keitelan all these big stars were in the film And I I had a small part in it and and I directed that too, right? You know James James Mangold Directed it wrote and directed it in mice I was one of the cops and most of my scenes were in this like bar and I would just sit around
and Stallone had put weight on and was going to try and win an Oscar. And this was Harvey Weinstein producing it in the height of his power and Ray Liotta and Harvey Keitelan all these big stars were in the film And I I had a small part in it and and I directed that too, right? You know James James Mangold Directed it wrote and directed it in mice I was one of the cops and most of my scenes were in this like bar and I would just sit around|||史泰龙为了尝试赢得奥斯卡奖而增肥了。那是正处于权势巅峰的哈维·韦恩斯坦（Harvey Weinstein）制片的作品，雷·利奥塔、哈维·凯特尔以及所有这些大明星都在这部电影里，我在里面有个小角色……而且这也是你导演的，对吧？你知道的，詹姆斯——詹姆斯·曼高德（James Mangold）执导的，他自编自导的，在老鼠……我是其中一个警察，我大部分的戏份都是在一个类似于酒吧的地方，我当时就只是坐在那儿……
Waiting for my one line. So Stallone would talk and De Niro would talk and then finally it would be my line and I'd be like, yeah for sure. And then, and then. Sounds like me in Kingdom. No, you had a great, you were phenomenal. No, Jason. Turn left.
Waiting for my one line. So Stallone would talk and De Niro would talk and then finally it would be my line and I'd be like, yeah for sure. And then, and then. Sounds like me in Kingdom. No, you had a great, you were phenomenal. No, Jason. Turn left.|||等待我说出我那唯一的一句台词。所以史泰龙会说话，德尼罗会说话，然后终于轮到我的台词了，我的反应大概是：“是的，绝对的。”然后，然后……听起来就像我在《王国的裂痕》（Kingdom）里的表现。不，你表现得很棒，你太惊艳了。不，杰森。向左转。
No, no, no. Jason, by the way, sidebar, sidebar, Jason had one of my favorite lines ever delivered in the film and you know what it is. He He's like hey driver. Are you late for something? That you guys are cruising along the desert fuck I love that I'll be Dobby scared out of my mind, but I was on the set of Copland just watching everything happen and there was this young director James Mangold and I was watching him and he was arguing with Stallone and getting into all this creative stuff with with
No, no, no. Jason, by the way, sidebar, sidebar, Jason had one of my favorite lines ever delivered in the film and you know what it is. He He's like hey driver. Are you late for something? That you guys are cruising along the desert fuck I love that I'll be Dobby scared out of my mind, but I was on the set of Copland just watching everything happen and there was this young director James Mangold and I was watching him and he was arguing with Stallone and getting into all this creative stuff with with|||不，不，不。杰森，顺便说一句，题外话，题外话，杰森在电影里贡献了我最喜欢的台词之一，你知道那是什么吗？他——他就像是：“嘿，司机。你是有什么急事吗？”当时你们开着车在沙漠里闲逛，操，我太喜欢那句台词了，我要是遇到这事非吓死不可。但我当时在《警察帝国》的片场，只是看着周围发生的一切，当时年轻的导演詹姆斯·曼高德也在那儿，我看着他跟史泰龙争论，并跟……
With De Niro and Ray Lee and just like he was alive He had this energy coming out of him and I was sitting there waiting for my line and I'm like, yeah And I finally at lunch. I walked up to him. I didn't really know him. I said, hey man, can I ask you a question? So do what's up? He said I said, how, I walked up to him, I didn't really know him, I said, hey man, can I ask you a question? He said, yeah, what's up? He said, I said, how do I get your job? Yeah. How do I get your job? You want to work 60 minutes an hour, not just 10.
With De Niro and Ray Lee and just like he was alive He had this energy coming out of him and I was sitting there waiting for my line and I'm like, yeah And I finally at lunch. I walked up to him. I didn't really know him. I said, hey man, can I ask you a question? So do what's up? He said I said, how, I walked up to him, I didn't really know him, I said, hey man, can I ask you a question? He said, yeah, what's up? He said, I said, how do I get your job? Yeah. How do I get your job? You want to work 60 minutes an hour, not just 10.|||与德尼罗和雷·利奥塔探讨各种创意相关的东西，感觉他整个人生机勃勃。他身上散发着那种能量，而我当时正坐在那儿等我的台词，心想：好吧。我终于在吃午饭时朝他走了过去。其实我跟他并不太熟。我说：“嘿，老兄，我能问你个问题吗？”他说：“什么事？”我说：“怎么……”我走到他跟前，其实我跟他并不太熟，我说：“嘿，老兄，我能问你个问题吗？”他说：“行啊，什么事？”我说：“我怎么才能得到你这份工作？”对。我怎么才能得到你这份工作？你想一小时干满60分钟，而不仅仅是10分钟。
And he said, you gotta write. And I said, okay, well how do you do that? He goes, well, do you know how to write? I go, yeah. He goes, well, do you have an idea? I said, kinda. He said, well, what I do is I use note cards. And I outline, and so then when I get all my cards,
And he said, you gotta write. And I said, okay, well how do you do that? He goes, well, do you know how to write? I go, yeah. He goes, well, do you have an idea? I said, kinda. He said, well, what I do is I use note cards. And I outline, and so then when I get all my cards,|||他说：“你得写作。”我说：“好吧，那你平时是怎么做的？”他说：“你会写作吗？”我说：“会啊。”他说：“那你有什么点子吗？”我说：“算是有吧。”他说：“好吧，我的做法是使用便签卡。我写出大纲，然后等我把所有的便签卡都弄好之后，”
then I start writing the scenes. And so I went back to my hotel, and I was staying in the Essex House in New York, you know that hotel? It has a big, it has the big, beautiful park views, right? I had the shittiest room in the hotel. I had the back, tiny little room in the back of the hotel that looked out over an alley, and I went home,
then I start writing the scenes. And so I went back to my hotel, and I was staying in the Essex House in New York, you know that hotel? It has a big, it has the big, beautiful park views, right? I had the shittiest room in the hotel. I had the back, tiny little room in the back of the hotel that looked out over an alley, and I went home,|||然后我才开始写具体的场景。于是我回到了酒店，我当时住在纽约的埃塞克斯酒店（Essex House），你知道那家酒店吗？它有很大、很漂亮的公园景观，对吧？我住的是全酒店最烂的房间。我住在酒店背面一个朝向小巷的极小的房间里，我回了房间，
and I went to the drug store, I got note cards, I got pen, and I started writing the note cards and outlining the script, but I had a really small room. And I had the note cards kind of all over the room, and I'd go to work and come back in more note cards, and I had this whole crazy system. And one day I came back, and the note cards had all been moved and cleaned up.
and I went to the drug store, I got note cards, I got pen, and I started writing the note cards and outlining the script, but I had a really small room. And I had the note cards kind of all over the room, and I'd go to work and come back in more note cards, and I had this whole crazy system. And one day I came back, and the note cards had all been moved and cleaned up.|||然后我去药店买了一些便签卡和笔，开始写便签卡并勾勒剧本大纲，但我房间真的很小。我的便签卡几乎贴满了整个房间，我每天去上班，回来后又会写更多便签卡，我搞出了一套疯狂的系统。有一天我回来，发现所有的便签卡都被移走并清理干净了。
And I'm like, who did this? And they told me it was Manuela, the housekeeper. So I found Manuela, I'm Manuela, you can't do this. I'm writing a movie, so I found Manuela, and she's like, what? And I told her it's about these guys who go to Vegas and accidentally kill a hooker and then have to chop her up. And she's like, oh my God, then what happens? And I had the script up all throughout the room, it was on all the walls, so I was living in it.
And I'm like, who did this? And they told me it was Manuela, the housekeeper. So I found Manuela, I'm Manuela, you can't do this. I'm writing a movie, so I found Manuela, and she's like, what? And I told her it's about these guys who go to Vegas and accidentally kill a hooker and then have to chop her up. And she's like, oh my God, then what happens? And I had the script up all throughout the room, it was on all the walls, so I was living in it.|||我就想：这是谁干的？他们告诉我是管家曼努埃拉（Manuela）干的。于是我找到曼努埃拉，我说：“曼努埃拉，你不能这么做。我在写电影剧本，”我找到了曼努埃拉，她问：“怎么了？”我告诉她，故事讲的是几个去拉斯维加斯玩却不小心杀了一个妓女、然后不得不把她分尸的家伙。她听了之后说：“天哪，那接下来发生什么了？”我的剧本大纲贴满了整个房间的墙壁，所以我相当于生活在剧本的世界里。
One day I came back and I went to go in the room and the key didn't work and I went down and they said, Mr. Berg, we have a problem, we have to move your room. And I'm like, holy shit. They took me up to the top floor, I went to turn to where the shitty rooms were, they go, no, you're this way,
One day I came back and I went to go in the room and the key didn't work and I went down and they said, Mr. Berg, we have a problem, we have to move your room. And I'm like, holy shit. They took me up to the top floor, I went to turn to where the shitty rooms were, they go, no, you're this way,|||有一天我回来，去开房门时发现钥匙不管用了，我下楼去问，他们说：“伯格先生，我们遇到了一个问题，我们得给你换个房间。”我当时想：卧槽。他们把我带到了顶楼，我正准备往那些破烂房间的方向走，他们说：“不，您往这边走，”
to where the good rooms were, walked me down into the park suite and I walk in this beautiful suite and the staff at the Essex house had cleared out the walls and put my script up on the walls no man well it told us what you're doing we wish you the best of luck come on that's amazing that that moment really changed everything for me. That's incredible. I never knew that. Dude, dude. Pete, Jesus, that's fucking great.
to where the good rooms were, walked me down into the park suite and I walk in this beautiful suite and the staff at the Essex house had cleared out the walls and put my script up on the walls no man well it told us what you're doing we wish you the best of luck come on that's amazing that that moment really changed everything for me. That's incredible. I never knew that. Dude, dude. Pete, Jesus, that's fucking great.|||朝着豪华房间的方向走去，把我领进了公园套房。我走进了这间美丽的套房，埃塞克斯酒店的工作人员居然清理了墙壁，把我的剧本贴在了墙上——不，是曼努埃拉告诉了我们你在做什么，我们祝你一切顺利——拜托，这太惊人了！那一刻真的改变了我的一切。这简直不可思议。我以前从不知道这件事。老兄，老兄。皮特，天哪，这他妈太棒了。
Dude, that's incredible. That's so fucking incredible. What a great story about humanity, people and belief and all that kind of, also I like to think that Manuela, before she knew it was a screenplay, she was nervous because she had all these cards about going to Vegas and killing the hookers.
Dude, that's incredible. That's so fucking incredible. What a great story about humanity, people and belief and all that kind of, also I like to think that Manuela, before she knew it was a screenplay, she was nervous because she had all these cards about going to Vegas and killing the hookers.|||老兄，这太不可思议了。这他妈太不可思议了。这是一个关于人性、关于人与人之间的信任以及诸如此类美好的故事，另外我宁愿这样想：在曼努埃拉知道这是一个电影剧本之前，她其实挺紧张的，因为她手里全都是关于去拉斯维加斯杀妓女的卡片。
She's like, I got a serial killer here. Well, Pete, how did you take your, you know, your very, you've got a very, your taste, your sensibility, your personality is very, you know, seasoned and no bullshit. And, you know, there's no real artifice to you which I just fucking love. And yet, and you've somehow managed to take that
She's like, I got a serial killer here. Well, Pete, how did you take your, you know, your very, you've got a very, your taste, your sensibility, your personality is very, you know, seasoned and no bullshit. And, you know, there's no real artifice to you which I just fucking love. And yet, and you've somehow managed to take that|||她心里肯定想：我这儿藏了个连环杀人犯啊。话说回来，皮特，你是如何把你的——你知道的，你的审美、你的艺术敏感度、你的个性非常……你知道的，阅历丰富且从不废话。而且，你知道的，你身上没有什么虚伪的做作，我他妈太喜欢这一点了。然而，你却不知怎么成功地把这些特质……
and mold it into an actual visual aesthetic too. Where did that come from? Like the style of your films, the way in which they're shot, the way in which they're cut, the actors you hire, the things you ask them to do and not to do, like how is that shaped? I mean the things that I think that I do that tend to work the best, like if it's Friday Night Lights
and mold it into an actual visual aesthetic too. Where did that come from? Like the style of your films, the way in which they're shot, the way in which they're cut, the actors you hire, the things you ask them to do and not to do, like how is that shaped? I mean the things that I think that I do that tend to work the best, like if it's Friday Night Lights|||塑造成了一种实际的视觉美学。这究竟是哪来的？比如你电影的风格、它们的拍摄方式、剪辑方式、你雇佣的演员、你要求他们做和不做的事情，这一切是如何成型的？我的意思是，我认为我所做的最有效的事情，比如《胜利之光》（Friday Night Lights）
or The Kingdom or Deepwater Horizon or Patriots Day, these are films that I do a tremendous amount of research on, you know, I'm kind of a psycho about that. I'm in Tel Aviv right now. Last night we had a missile attack that was pretty amazing and somewhat terrifying. I've always been someone who likes to see things for myself. That generally translates to my writing. And I try to have as deep of an almost anthropological or almost journalistic understanding of my world.
or The Kingdom or Deepwater Horizon or Patriots Day, these are films that I do a tremendous amount of research on, you know, I'm kind of a psycho about that. I'm in Tel Aviv right now. Last night we had a missile attack that was pretty amazing and somewhat terrifying. I've always been someone who likes to see things for myself. That generally translates to my writing. And I try to have as deep of an almost anthropological or almost journalistic understanding of my world.|||或者是《王国的裂痕》（The Kingdom）、《深海浩劫》（Deepwater Horizon）或者《爱国者日》（Patriots Day），这些电影我都做了大量的研究，你知道的，我在这方面简直像个神经病。我现在正在特拉维夫。昨晚我们这里遭到了导弹袭击，相当震撼，也有点吓人。我一直是个喜欢亲眼见证事物的人。这通常会转化到我的剧本创作中。我尽量对我的世界保持一种近乎人类学或近乎新闻学层面的深入理解。
So, I went to Saudi Arabia a long time ago before we did The Kingdom and lived there for three weeks and got as much of an understanding as I could of that culture. And once I kind of feel like I've done that work and I understand the world, I mean, when I did Lone Survivor, I went to Iraq and embedded with the Navy Seal platoon for a month on the border of Syria. And that helped me make a better film.
So, I went to Saudi Arabia a long time ago before we did The Kingdom and lived there for three weeks and got as much of an understanding as I could of that culture. And once I kind of feel like I've done that work and I understand the world, I mean, when I did Lone Survivor, I went to Iraq and embedded with the Navy Seal platoon for a month on the border of Syria. And that helped me make a better film.|||所以，在拍《王国的裂痕》很久以前，我去了沙特阿拉伯并在那里生活了三周，尽可能多地去理解那种文化。一旦我觉得我完成了那项工作并且理解了这个世界——我的意思是，自我拍摄《孤独的幸存者》（Lone Survivor）以来，我去了伊拉克，并在叙利亚边境的海豹突击队排里嵌入式体验了一个月。这帮助我拍出了一部更好的电影。
And that helps me in theory communicate with, you know, someone, you know, like when we were doing the scene in the kingdom where they were gonna cut your head off. I've tried to have a proximity, certainly never to that kind of level of violence, but to at least understand as best as I can what these executions were looking like and how they might have gone down. And that I think could help me help you reach an appropriate level of Terror and a willingness to fight which you did so well in that
And that helps me in theory communicate with, you know, someone, you know, like when we were doing the scene in the kingdom where they were gonna cut your head off. I've tried to have a proximity, certainly never to that kind of level of violence, but to at least understand as best as I can what these executions were looking like and how they might have gone down. And that I think could help me help you reach an appropriate level of Terror and a willingness to fight which you did so well in that|||理论上讲，这有助于我与……你知道的，与某个人进行沟通，比如当我们在拍《王国的裂痕》中他们要砍掉你脑袋的那场戏时。我一直试图保持一种贴近感，当然绝不是那种级别的暴力，但至少要尽可能去理解这些行刑看起来是什么样的，以及它们可能是如何发生的。我认为这可以帮到我，让我协助你达到恰当的恐惧感以及强烈的求生欲——你在那场戏里表现得太出色了。
Which I found fascinating and I've had so many people talk about that scene and how Jason Bateman this sweet funny guy went fucking psycho to save himself. And that really comes from the research. So then you're looking for a level of authenticity that then just naturally lends itself to, let's say, a handheld camera, de-saturated color, blah, blah, blah. So all of these things, you're engineering it
这让我觉得非常着迷，很多人都跟我讨论过那个场景：杰森·贝特曼这个温柔、搞笑的家伙是如何为了自救而变得彻底疯狂的。这真的源于研究。所以当你追求那种真实感时，它就会自然而然地引导你采用手持摄影机、降低饱和度的色彩等等。所以所有这些，你都是
from a very organic place. You're not kind of going backwards into an aesthetic. You're just going, yeah. And you know, when I was acting on Chicago Hope, back in those days, I learned so much, because we were doing 28 episodes a season, and we would have 28 different directors coming in. And I learned so much, and a lot of these directors were,
从一个非常自然的角度去设计的。你不是在盲目地倒退去追求某种美学。你只是顺其自然。你知道的，当我在《芝加哥希望》当演员的时候，在那个时期，我学到了很多，因为我们一季要拍 28 集，会有 28 个不同的导演来执导。我学到了很多，而且其中很多导演，
they tried to have feature careers and they were a bit older and they were angry. And they were trying to prove that they were Tarantino or Scorsese and they would just spend so much time setting up shots and doing all this stuff and we as actors would sit around waiting for all this equipment and I'm like, what the fuck are we doing here?
他们试图拍出剧情片的风范，他们年纪大了一点，而且满腔怒火。他们试图证明自己是昆汀或马丁·斯科塞斯，于是他们会花大量时间去布置镜头、搞这搞那，而我们作为演员就坐在那儿干等这些器材。我就在想，我们他妈的到底在这干什么？
I want to act, I want to feel free to not be beholden to the, and you guys have all seen it, the machinery of filmmaking where cranes and dollies and lighting and hair and makeup and every, it seems like it impacts everything other than the actual acting. All right, and so Pete Stylist, yeah, multiple cameras,
我想演戏，我想感到自由，不想受制于——你们大家都见过——电影制作的机器，那些吊臂、轨道车、灯光、发型、化妆以及所有这一切，它似乎影响了除了真正演戏之外的一切。好吧，所以皮特的风格，是的，多台摄像机，
handheld cameras going at the same time. And when they run out, we're shooting on film, and they'd run out of film, the AC would just put the camera on the ground, reload it, put another magazine of film on top of the camera while the other two are still rolling and while we're resetting back to the top of the scene.
手持摄像机同时拍摄。当胶片用完时——我们当时是用胶片拍摄的——如果胶片用完了，助理摄像师就会把摄像机放到地上，重新装填，在摄像机顶部装上一盘新的胶片杂志，而另外两台摄像机还在继续拍摄，同时我们回到场景的起点重新开始。
No fucking way. Like multiple takes over and over and over again without ever cutting. Just reloading the cameras quietly. at the scene like multiple takes over and over and over again without ever cutting, just reloading the cameras quietly. I remember when we were rehearsing Hancock, remember we would have all those crazy rehearsals with Will and Charlize. On soundstage with the key of it.
真他妈绝了。就像是一次又一次地进行多个长镜头拍摄，中间从不喊停。只是静静地重新装填摄像机。在场景中就像进行多次、多次、多次的连续拍摄，中间从不喊停，只是静静地重新装填摄像机。我记得我们在排练《全民超人汉考克》的时候，记得我们和威尔还有查理兹有过那些疯狂的排练。在带有特定基调的摄影棚里。
And when I first met Charlize, she came up to me because Jason and I had worked together and I knew Will and I think Will had heard a little bit about my style of work and Charlize, she came up to me, because Jason and I had worked together, and I knew Will, and I think Will had heard a little bit about my style of work, and Charlize said, you know, Pete, I understand, I've talked to Jason, I know how you like to do this kind of wild thing, and move around lots of cameras, just so you know, I don't work that way. I need a certain amount of organization,
当我第一次见到查理兹时，她朝我走来，因为我和杰森合作过，我认识威尔，我想威尔可能稍微听说过我的工作风格，而查理兹她朝我走来，因为我和杰森合作过，我认识威尔，我想威尔可能稍微听说过我的工作风格，查理兹说，你知道的，皮特，我明白，我和杰森聊过，我知道你喜欢这种疯狂的方式，用很多摄像机四处移动，但我要告诉你的是，我不习惯那种工作方式。我需要一定程度的组织性，
and there has to be a system where I can, and I'm like, Charlize, no problem, I got you. We'll do it, we'll cut and we'll reset and do it. And then like the first day I was working with Jason and we were just going off and Will was into it and I would come up for Charlize and in about an hour she came up to me and she said, you know that thing you're doing with Jason,
必须有一个系统让我能够……我说，查理兹，没问题，我懂你。我们会这么做的，我们会喊停，然后重新布置再拍。然后就像我跟杰森合作的第一天，我们尽情发挥，威尔也很投入，我走到查理兹面前，大约一个小时后，她朝我走来，对我说，你知道你对杰森做的那种事吗？
do that to me. And I want that too. Pete, I was thinking about you the other day. I was down in Fort Worth, Texas, not a bit. And I was truly, I was doing this thing. I was working with Taylor Sheridan, he was a great guy. And so I was staying at this hotel and it was the fall. And I hear, I'm in my this hotel and it was the fall
也对我这么做。我也要那样。皮特，前几天我一直在想你。我在德克萨斯州沃思堡，一点不假。我真的，我在做这件事。我和泰勒·谢里丹一起工作，他是个很棒的家伙。所以我住在一家酒店里，那是秋天。我听到，我在我这家酒店里，那是秋天，
and I hear, I'm in my hotel room and I'm trying to go over my shit that I'm working on. I keep hearing this like, sadasasaa, sadasasaa, ah, sadasasaa. Like what the fuck is like, is my phone on? And I keep looking around the room, the TV's not on, I go out in the thing and I look out and I can just see over the treetops in the distance this Stadium and I fucking look at him on my phone and it's a fucking Texas high school football game
我听到，我在我的酒店房间里，我正试图复习我正在处理的事情。我一直听到这种声音，萨达萨萨，萨达萨萨，啊，萨达萨萨。就像，这他妈是什么声音，我的手机开着吗？我一直在房间里到处看，电视没开，我走到外面，朝外望去，我能透过远处的树梢看到那个体育场，我他妈看了一眼手机，这他妈是一场德克萨斯州的高中橄榄球比赛。
Yeah, oh wow and the stadium is packed and I can hear the fans and I can hear the announcement. I was like holy Shit, it was Friday fucking night lights man. Like it was incredible. Yeah. Yeah, how did that, how did, so for the listener, yeah, Pete brought us Friday Night Lights, the film, and then shepherded the television series to us as well by doing what the pilot, probably the first couple, and EP'd the whole thing, right? Yes. You're, the writer, your second cousin to the writer, perhaps? Yes, Buzz're the writer, your second cousin to the writer perhaps?
是的，哦，哇，体育场座无虚席，我能听到球迷的欢呼声，我能听到广播。我当时想，天哪，那是周五疯狂的橄榄球之夜啊，兄弟。简直太不可思议了。是的。是的，那是怎么，怎么——所以对于听众来说，是的，皮特给我们带来了电影版的《胜利之光》，然后通过执导试播集（大概前几集）并担任整部剧的执行制片人，把这部电视剧也带给了我们，对吧？是的。你是，编剧，你是编剧的远亲，对吧？是的，巴兹——你是编剧的远亲，对吧？
Yes, Buzz Bessinger's my second cousin. Was that helpful in it finding its way to you or did it happen without that? It was, you know, I had followed the book and read the book and Buzz used to push me to try and make it. At the time I actually didn't really have the juice. There were a lot of filmmakers that wanted it,
是的，巴兹·贝辛格是我的远亲。这对于这个项目最终找到你有什么帮助吗？还是说这一切的发生并没有借助这层关系？是这样的，你知道的，我一直关注并读过这本书，巴兹过去常常催促我去试着把它拍出来。当时我其实并没有那个影响力。有很多电影人都想要它，
and Brian Grazer controlled it. And I would call Brian and just sort of check in with him. And I knew they were going through a list of, you know, some pretty top-tier directors. And Brian was always nice, and he was pretty honest, saying, you know, maybe we'll get to you. And two directors, one fell out and one Brian got annoyed with and fired.
而布莱恩·格雷泽掌握着版权。我会打电话给布莱恩，跟他联络一下。我知道他们当时正在考虑一份相当顶级的导演名单。布莱恩总是很友好，而且也算坦诚，他说，你知道的，也许以后会轮到你。后来有两个导演，一个退出了，另一个让布莱恩感到恼火并被解雇了。
And he called me and he said, okay dude, it's yours. And that was an incredible experience. And you know, when I was doing Friday Night Lights, I went and I was, I think I was 41 at the time, flew down to Texas and moved into a high school, this school, Austin Westlake, and I stayed with a football player's family, let me live in his house,
他打电话给我说，好了，伙计，它是你的了。那是一次不可思议的经历。你知道的，当我拍摄《胜利之光》时，我去了那里，当时我大概 41 岁，飞到德克萨斯州，搬进了一所高中——奥斯汀韦斯特莱克高中，我和一个橄榄球运动员的家人住在一起，他们让我住在他们家里，
and I lived on a futon in Koyani, who was a wide receiver for Austin Westlake, an 18-year-old, I was probably 17 or 18 at the time, and I went to high school with him every day, and I went to football practice with them every day, and I went to football practice and lived with this team, and it was really an amazing experience. That's really cool.
我睡在科亚尼家里的一个折叠床上，他是奥斯汀韦斯特莱克队的外接手，一个 18 岁的孩子，当时我大概 17 或 18 岁，我每天和他一起去上高中，每天和他一起去参加橄榄球训练，我参加橄榄球训练并和这支球队生活在一起，这真的是一段奇妙的经历。这真的很酷。
And that's why it feels so real and authentic, and just the way in which you just shot the sport as well. What was your, did you play a lot of football growing up? I played high school football, but I tried, I wanted to be a quarterback. My ego was like, I'm going to be a quarterback and I was horrible. So for three years, I tried to play quarterback very unsuccessfully. In my senior year in high school, my coach moved me to defensive end.
这就是为什么它感觉如此真实和地道，还有你拍摄这项运动的方式也是如此。你小时候经常踢橄榄球吗？我上高中时踢过橄榄球，但我试过，我想当四分卫。我的自我感觉非常好，觉得“我要当个四分卫”，结果我烂透了。所以三年来，我非常失败地尝试去当四分卫。在我高中的最后一年，我的教练把我调到了防守端锋的位置。
And I really realized I should have done that all along because I liked hitting people and I didn't have the pressure. I would get too anxious and couldn't remember the plays and just had some horrible disasters as quarterback. When I finally moved to defense, I developed a real love for the game. But the book is about so much more than football and I think that's why the show has worked so well.
我真的意识到我早该这么做了，因为我喜欢撞击别人，而且我没有那种压力。我总是过于焦虑，记不住战术，作为四分卫经历了一些可怕的灾难。当我最终转到防守端时，我培养了对这项运动真正的热爱。但这本书讲的不仅仅是橄榄球，我想这也是这部剧如此成功的原因。
It's really just, you know, you're a huge sports fan, Jason. I know how much baseball means to you, right? Yeah. I remember when I was a kid, I played football when I was really young, and I remember my mom telling me to go to this guy's house to get fitted for the equipment,
这其实就是，你知道的，你是个超级体育迷，杰森。我知道棒球对你有多重要，对吧？是的。我记得小时候，我很小的时候踢过橄榄球，我记得我妈妈让我去一个家伙家里量身定制装备，
and so I did, and he gave me the mouth guard to fit my mouth. And the only good thing from the whole experience was that it tasted like mint. It was like a deep flavored. And I was like, oh, maybe I could do this because it tastes so good. That was the extent of my happiness.
于是我去了，他给了我一个护齿来贴合我的牙齿。整个经历中唯一的好处就是它尝起来有薄荷味。就像是一种浓郁的风味。当时我想，哦，也许我能干这个，因为这味道太好了。这就是我全部的快乐所在。
Go ahead, Will. Well, I just, I don't know where to start. Honestly, that's so funny. I mean, so much. I was like, oh, maybe there's a silver lining here because it takes a minute. Part of it's funny and then part of it's just a nothing story.
说吧，威尔。嗯，我只是，我不知道从何说起。老实说，太搞笑了。我的意思是，有那么多。我当时想，哦，也许这其中还有一线生机，因为它得花上一分钟。部分内容很搞笑，但另一部分纯粹是个无聊的故事。
It is a nothing story. And disturbing and you know. Hey, Pete, I'm sure that all your films have, and you mentioned a few of them, like have a place in your heart or in your life where you look back and they represented a thing, and I'm sure you learned a lot from them. Was there one of your films that really,
这确实是个无聊的故事。而且有点令人不安，你知道的。嘿，皮特，我确信你的所有电影都有——你提到了其中的几部——在你的心中或生活中占据一席之地，每当你回首往事，它们都代表着某种东西，我确信你从中学到了很多。有没有哪部电影，
for you, transported you and kind of, not like, hey, I figured it out, but more like, and again, not even necessarily your favorite, but something you just like, you learned a lot from, that was like a turning point film for you. I mean, there was a moment when I was, sometimes I answer that question, and I mean it by saying,
对你来说有着非凡的意义，带你进入了一种状态，不是那种“嘿，我终于开窍了”的感觉，而是那种——再次强调，甚至不一定是你的最爱，但就是让你学到了很多，对你来说是一个转折点的电影。我的意思是，曾有过这样一个时刻，有时我回答这个问题时，我的意思是，
you never set out to make a shitty movie, no filmmaker does. And we all understand how hard it is to make a good film And sometimes they're good and sometimes they absolutely suck But so hard to just make a movie that doesn't suck not a good just one that doesn't suck. It's so hard I don't think people appreciate that You know and people don't magic trick. It's not their responsibility to appreciate. Yeah, it's on us Yeah, you know I've had people just say, God, your movies,
你绝不会故意去拍一部烂片，没有哪个电影人都这样。我们都理解拍一部好电影有多么艰难，有时它们很好，有时它们简直糟透了。但是，仅仅拍一部不烂的电影就太难了，不是说要有多好，只要不烂就行。这太难了，我觉得人们并不理解这一点。你知道的，人们并不把它当成魔术。这不是他们的责任去理解。是的，这取决于我们。是的，你知道的，我曾听人直言不讳地说，天哪，你的电影，
that movie sucked. And I'm like, okay, fair enough. I mean, really, people would do that. Appreciate that. That wasn't my goal, I assure you. It's usually in the Boston area, by the way, that you get that, fuck you, dude, that fucking sucked, huh? For real, for real.
那部电影太烂了。我就说，好吧，有道理。我是说，真的有人会这么干。能理解这一点。那可不是我的目标，我向你保证。顺便说一句，通常是在波士顿地区，你才会听到这种评价：“操你妈的，伙计，那片子真他妈烂透了，哈？”千真万确，千真万确。
And they don't, but yeah, Boston's very direct. But I do love everything I've done, and I find that these are things that I try as hard as I can, and hopefully the result is good. So I do have connections to every film I've done. There was a moment when I was making Friday Night Lights, the movie, where we were going to film a scene,
而且他们不会……是的，波士顿人非常直率。但我确实热爱我所做过的一切，我发现这些都是我竭尽全力去完成的事情，希望结果是好的。所以我对我拍过的每一部电影都有很深的感情。记得有一次我在拍电影版《胜利之光》时，当时我们要拍一场戏，
there's a coin toss scene, there's a coin toss scene that's a big dramatic scene where all these schools have to decide who's going to be in the playoffs. And we'd been, but we scheduled for three nights to film this scene. It was a big scene, you know, a hundred extras, Billy Bob Thornton, all the principals were there and it was a complicated scene. And this was when I was starting to find a style with multiple cameras and what Jason was talking about.
有一场抛硬币的戏，那是一场非常重大的戏剧性戏份，所有的学校都要在那决定谁能进入季后赛。我们原本计划用三个晚上来拍这场戏。那是一场大戏，你知道的，有一百名群演，比利·鲍伯·松顿，所有主演都在场，而且场面很复杂。正是在那个时候，我开始摸索多机位拍摄的风格，也就是杰森刚才提到的那种。
Just keep moving and don't cut and shoot and do it. So we had three nights scheduled to shoot it. And we got up there and rehearsed it for a couple hours and I had the cameras going and we shot it in about two hours and we cut. And I'm like looking at Eric Heffron, who was my first AD and you've worked with him Jason, and he's looking at me and I'm like looking at Eric Heffron who was my first ADA and you've worked with him Jason and he's looking at me and I'm like,
只要不断移动，不要切镜头，直接开拍并完成它。所以我们原计划用三个晚上来拍。我们到了现场，排练了几个小时，我让机器运转起来，结果我们大概两个小时就拍完了，然后喊了停。我看着埃里克·赫夫伦，他当时是我的第一副导演——杰森你和他合作过——他看着我，我看着埃里克·赫夫伦——他当时是我的第一副导演，杰森你和他合作过，他看着我，我就在想，
do we have this scene? And he's like, I think we do. And this was two hours, we had three nights to shoot this scene. And we're standing there and the DP comes over and he's like, what just happened? I go, I'm not sure. And the script supervisor was all confused
我们拍完这场戏了吗？他说，我想我们拍完了。而这仅仅花了两个小时，我们原本有三个晚上来拍这场戏。我们就站在那儿，摄影指导走了过来，问道：“刚刚发生什么了？”我说：“我不太确定。”连场记都彻底迷糊了，
because he couldn't make sense of any of it. And I go, I think we've got it. And then the producer came over and he's like, you can't do this, I'm going to get in so much trouble. And I realized then that I was able to work in a way that I didn't realize was possible. And the actors loved it and and it came out great, and I loved it, and the studio saved a shitload of money.
因为他根本搞不懂这一切是怎么回事。我说：“我想我们已经拍好了。”然后制片人走了过来，说道：“你不能这么干，我要惹大麻烦了。”我当时才意识到，我能够以一种自己以前没意识到可能的方式进行创作。演员们很喜欢这种方式，成片效果也棒极了，我很喜欢，而且制片厂还省了大笔钱。
And that became, for me, kind of a personal sort of realization that there are not as many rules as we think there should be. Interesting. You know, I think the Successive Euroguys podcast is another example of that. You know, like, really? Like, this happened?
对我来说，这成为了一种个人的顿悟：原来世界上并没有我们想象中那么多必须遵守的规则。很有意思。你知道的，我觉得“Successive Euroguys”播客就是另一个例子。你知道的，真的吗？这竟然发生了？
That's what happens when you just go forward. You just did it and you followed no rules and you followed your hearts and you have this incredible relationship with each other and people responded to it. And I think that those are the kinds of signals or signs that I look for as I kind of chug through my life. Yeah, you know what else is great about that that particular specific style too is that it's super reliant on the team. Those camera operators and focus pullers,
这就是当你一往直前时会发生的事情。你只是去做了，不遵循任何规则，跟随自己的内心，你们彼此之间有着这种不可思议的关系，而人们对此产生了共鸣。我想，这些就是我在人生旅途中不断前行时所寻找的信号或迹象。是的，你知道这种特定风格的另一个绝妙之处在于它极度依赖团队。那些摄像师和跟焦员，
you can't get to them in between action and cut and they've got to be making decisions in the moment, watching and listening to the scene, making composition work, et cetera, et cetera, tagging certain things that they didn't get in the last take. And it's all that sort of teamwork that maybe is an exciting comparison for you to sports
在“Action”（开拍）和“Cut”（停）的间隙你根本无法接近他们，他们必须在当下做出决定，观看并倾听场景，确保构图完美，等等，等等，还要标记上一条没拍好的特定内容。所有这种团队合作，对你来说或许是一个激动人心的比对，可以联想到体育运动，
and to what you appreciate with your you know, your fellow linemen, as opposed to perhaps the quarterback route you could have taken where it's just like, oh, I'm the star and who cares who's blocking for me? I just need to, you know, you got more in the trenches and you potentially became more of a crew guy than a cast guy that you may have stayed had you gone the quarterback route
以及你对同伴——那些前锋的感激，而不是像你本可以走的四分卫路线那样，表现得就像“哦，我是明星，谁在乎谁在为我挡人？我只需要……”你知道的，你更多地深入前线，你可能最终成了一个剧组型的人，而不是演员型的人——如果你走了四分卫路线的话，你可能本来会保持那种状态，
or maybe just stayed, you just stayed as an actor. I don't know, I'm just such a big, I just love- Well, I think also everybody's probably really present, right, Pete? Like everybody's in it. For sure. As you say, Jason, everybody's listening, everybody's in it.
或者也许只是保持原样，你只是作为一个演员待在那里。我不知道，我只是太喜欢了——嗯，我也觉得每个人可能都在全情投入，对吧，皮特？就像每个人都融入其中一样。肯定的。正如你所说，杰森，每个人都在倾听，每个人都身在其中。
There's no chance to fuck off and get on your phone or whatever. You gotta be- It becomes kind of like a bit like theater or a live experience. So I've had a lot of actors say, like they've gone into some sort of creative blackout while we're doing it,
根本没有机会去偷懒玩手机或者干别的。你必须保持——这感觉有点像戏剧或现场体验。所以很多演员跟我说，他们在我们拍摄的过程中经历了一种某种形式的“创作黑洞”，
and they don't remember exactly what happened. And I've experienced that. I used to do theater and I loved it. And I'm sure you guys have felt that before where, you know. Sean won a Tony last year. I know you did, Sean, congratulations. Yeah, there we go. Did you ever- Goodbye Oscar, goodbye Oscar.
他们不记得具体发生了什么。我也经历过这种感觉。我以前演过戏剧，我很喜欢。我确信你们俩以前也感受过这种时刻，你知道的。肖恩去年赢得了一项托尼奖。我知道你做到了，肖恩，恭喜你。是的，就是这样。你有没有——再见奥斯卡，再见奥斯卡。
Did you ever find that- It's actually good night, sorry. You must have gotten into that flow state on stage where you're just in it and you don't necessarily remember it, you're not thinking- That's so true, from the second you start pacing backstage waiting for your entrance, right?
你有没有发现——其实是晚安，抱歉。你一定在舞台上进入过那种“心流状态”，你完全沉浸其中，不一定记得具体细节，也没有在思考——千真万确，从你在后台踱步等待上场的那一秒开始，对吧？
You're somewhere else a little bit, and then the second you step on, you're like, oh, there's just a couple shows here and there where you have your markers, where as you're talking in like a monologue or something, you go, from this point on, I have about 25 more minutes. Then I get to go home and eat pizza. And so, you know, you start having those markers.
你稍微去到了别的地方，然后当你迈上舞台的那一秒，你会想，哦，这里只有几个表演标记，当你在发表独白或类似的东西时，你会想，从这个点开始，我还有大约 25 分钟。然后我就可以回家吃披萨了。所以，你知道的，你开始有了那些标记。
But most of the time you're in it. Yeah, most of the time you don't have a choice but to be in it, right? Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show. Now Pete, I want to talk to you about potentially one of the most challenging periods in your career,
但大部分时间你都身处其中。是的，大部分时间你别无选择，只能身处其中，对吧？是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。现在皮特，我想跟你聊聊你职业生涯中可能最具挑战性的时期之一，
going through the work experience with Justin Theroux on Leftovers. How did you manage to just keep your head up, go forward and say they're not all gonna be like this? I did see that he managed to work in a shirt, like he went tarps off in a running scene in the pilot, which probably was his call. Well, and fucking Theroux stole your sleeveless look.
那就是和贾斯汀·塞洛克斯一起经历《守望尘世》的工作经历。你是如何做到昂首挺胸、继续前行，并告诉自己“不会每部作品都这样的”？我确实看到他在试集里的一场跑步戏中赤裸上身，成功地穿了一件衬衫——或者说没穿衬衫，这可能是他自己的主意。好吧，他妈的塞洛克斯还偷了你的无袖造型。
Pete's got a great war cry basically, physical work war cry. He'll take, he'll grab his short sleeves, he'll pull them up over the top of his shoulder cap and turn his t-shirts into shirtless. I like that. Justin just cuts off the sleeves, but Pete's actually got a move there
皮特有一个标志性的战吼，基本上是身体上的战吼。他会抓住他的短袖，把它们往上拉到肩膀头上方，把他的 T 恤变成无袖的。我挺喜欢那样的。贾斯汀只是剪掉袖子，但皮特实际上有一个动作，
that creates the sleeveless look and it gets everyone fired up. You know, when we were getting ready to cast leftovers, Damon Lindelof, who is a genius, was telling me, I was directing the pilot and he wanted me to do kind of what I wanted to do and he certainly wasn't giving me mandates, but he really was encouraging me to meet with Justin Theroux
能营造出无袖的效果，这能让每个人都充满激情。你知道的，当我们准备为《守望尘世》选角时，戴安娜·林德洛夫——他是个天才——告诉我，我当时在执导试集，他希望我按照自己想做的方式去做，他当然没有给我下达什么硬性任务，但他确实极力鼓励我去见见贾斯汀·塞洛克斯。
and I met with him and I couldn't figure him out. I'd never seen anything like it. I thought it was a bit. You thought Damon was having a laugh. He can't figure himself out, so I mean, keep going. And you know, the tattoos, and I've never seen someone with less body fat. There's just no one.
我见了他，却完全摸不透他。我从未见过这样的人。我觉得这有点像是个恶作剧。你以为戴曼是在开玩笑。他自己都摸不透状况，所以我的意思是，继续说。你知道的，那些纹身，而且我从未见过体脂率比他更低的人。根本没有。
He's so ripped and so intense, and I was like, I didn't get it. And then I met him, and Damon's like, he wants to meet you again, and I was like, I didn't get it. And then I met him and Dan's like, he wants to meet you again and we met again. And I still didn't totally get it, but he covered his sleeves, he wore a shirt. So I didn't have the tattoos. And then we met a third time.
他身材如此健美，又如此充满压迫感，当时我想，我搞不懂。然后我见了他，戴曼说，他还想见你一次，当时我想，我搞不懂。然后我又见了他，戴曼说，他想再见你一次，我们又见面了。但我还是没有完全搞懂，不过他把袖子遮住了，穿了件衬衫。所以我没看到那些纹身。然后我们见了第三次。
And I guess he wore me down a little bit and he was Play this role and I have to say once he showed up on set that guy is legit He he did such a great job. He covered the tattoos He got his haircut looking like cuz I didn't buy him as a Midwestern cop, you know I was having trouble seeing that and he really transformed himself and That show is so fucking he looks like a West Village like he's just kind of like a downtown New York dandy that guy So if he doesn't you know what I mean like you can't even Andy
我想他多少有点把我磨合妥协了，他就是来演这个角色的，我必须承认，一旦他出现在片场，这家伙绝对是货真价实的。他干得太棒了。他遮住了纹身，把头发剪成了那种样子——因为我一开始不相信他是个中西部警察，你知道的，我很难把这联系起来，但他真的完成了蜕变，那部剧简直太——他看起来像个西村人——就像是个纽约市中心的纨绔子弟，那家伙。所以如果他没有，你知道我的意思吗——你甚至都看不到——安迪？
No, he doesn't you can't even see him above 23rd Street, so forget For sure, but yeah, he's a real actor and you know. He is. He really is, and that show. Such a good writer. Pete, that show is so good. You and Damon and then what Mimi Lieder did afterwards. Mimi did a great job. Keeping that thing going, like it's just fucking beautiful.
不，他没有，你甚至都看不到他在 23 街以北出现，所以忘了吧。肯定的，但话说回来，他是个真正的演员，你知道的。他是。他真的是，而且那部剧。编剧太棒了。皮特，那部剧太棒了。你和戴曼，然后是咪咪·莱德后来的创作。咪咪干得太棒了。让那种风格延续下去，简直美妙绝伦。
Max Richter's music, it's just. Max Richter the best. But you made all those decisions setting that show up with the way it looked, music, it just, and you make, but you made all those decisions setting that show up with the way it looked, the way it sounded, who's in it, where we're shooting it, what the crew is, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. And so thank you for that, among all the other things you set up.
麦克斯·里希特的音乐，简直了。麦克斯·里希特是最棒的。但你在筹备那部剧时做出了所有这些决定——它的视觉风格、音乐，简直了，但你在筹备那部剧时做出了所有这些决定——它的视觉风格、听觉风格、演员阵容、拍摄地点、剧组人员等等，等等，等等。所以为此谢谢你，以及感谢你所筹备的所有其他事情。
I just love your taste. No, I appreciate it. I was thinking about what you were saying, I'm kind of going back a little bit, but I've had this same frustration about, and I love hearing about your style, Pete, because there is nothing, I think it's even, the hardest thing to do is to make a funny film,
我就是喜欢你的品味。不，我很感激。我刚才在想你刚才说的话，我稍微把话题扯回一点点，但我对这一点也有过同样的沮丧感，而且我很高兴听到你的风格，皮特，因为没有什么——我觉得甚至，最难做的事情就是拍一部搞笑的电影，
because there's generally no flow on set, and you're turning around, and you're doing, and all this kind of shit, and there's nothing less fun than trying to make a comedy film. They're really fucking tough to do. And because the system is set up, it's set against you. And that's why often really funny films that break out
因为片场通常没有什么连贯性，你要不断调转镜头，拍摄，搞这些乱七八糟的事情，没有什么比试图拍一部喜剧电影更让人觉得毫无乐趣的了。拍喜剧真的他妈太难了。因为整个体制的建立就是与你作对的。这就是为什么那些脱颖而出的真正搞笑的电影，
are films that are small films that come out of nowhere because they don't have the budget to fuck around and to have a big company move and all this shit. It's just young people who are like just grabbing cameras, throwing cameras on their shoulders and getting it. Two or three, you know, two cameras, handheld, blah, blah, blah, and that immediacy is what you need in comedy and it just doesn't exist in a bigger format.
往往是那些预算很小的、凭空出现的独立电影，因为它们没有预算去瞎折腾，也没有大公司的繁文缛节。那只是一群年轻人，就像是抓起摄像机，把摄像机扛在肩上就开拍。两三台，你知道的，两台手持摄像机，巴拉巴拉，那种即兴感正是喜剧所需要的，而在更大的制作规模中根本不存在这种东西。
Would you agree with that? I saw Sean Baker's film, his new film, Anora, have you guys seen it? Yeah, Anora is incredible. No, I haven't seen it. That's the hardest I've laughed in a movie in quite a while. That's great. And Will, did you see it, Sean?
你同意吗？我看过肖恩·贝克的电影，他的新片《阿诺拉》，你们看过吗？对，太不可思议了。《阿诺拉》太棒了。不，我没看过。那是我在电影院里笑得最大声的一次，已经很久没有过了。太棒了。威尔，你看过吗，肖恩？
Yeah, I saw it, yeah. What's the film? Anorah. Oh, yeah, we were just talking about it. I haven't seen it yet. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You've got to check that out. That's fantastic.
看过，我看过。什么电影？《阿诺拉》。哦，对，我们刚才正在聊呢。我还没看过呢。对，对，对，对。你一定要去看看。太棒了。
I mean, when that dude is in the courtroom and the judge throws him out and he starts objecting like he's part of the legal defense team. I just haven't laughed that hard. And to your point, Will, it's just, I'm a big fan of Sean Baker and it's just loose, wild. You don't know who these people are that are in the cast. I remember seeing Rushmore in the theater when it first came out and feeling like,
我是说，当那个家伙在法庭上，法官把他赶出去时，他开始提出异议，好像他是法律辩护团队的一员。我真的没笑得这么厉害过。说到你的观点，威尔，这只是，我是肖恩·贝克的超级粉丝，这部电影非常随性、狂野。你甚至不知道演员阵容里都是些什么人。我记得当年《青春年少》刚上映时去电影院看，那种感觉就像是，
fuck, this is fucking great. Because there wasn't any- There's no winking. Well, there's no, yeah, and there was no pretense. It was just, they came out, obviously they had Bill Murray, but you got the sense that these guys were young and they didn't know what they were doing, and they were gonna try shit,
操，这他妈太棒了。因为里面没有任何——没有挤眉弄眼。好吧，没有，是的，而且没有任何矫揉造作。这只是，他们出来了，很明显他们有比尔·默瑞，但你会有一种感觉：这些家伙很年轻，他们不知道自己在做什么，他们要尝试各种疯狂的东西，
and they weren't part of the system yet. Now, Pete, you being an actor, how does your, do you have more patience or less patience with actors as a director? You know, I recognize, I think I have less patience at times and I value, I have so much more respect for actors who really come to bring it, who are really there to work, and who are smart, and who are thinking, I just worked with Betty Gilpin,
而且他们当时还不属于好莱坞体制的一部分。现在，皮特，作为一个演员，你作为导演对演员更有耐心还是更没有耐心？你知道，我意识到，有时候我更没有耐心，而我更看重、更尊重那些真正全力以赴、真正为了工作而来、聪明且富有思考的演员。我刚刚和贝蒂·吉尔平合作过，
I don't know if you guys have met Betty Gilpin, she's in something I just did, American Primeval, and she's just a wonderful, wonderful actress. Which by the way, Amanda saw my wife over the past couple of weeks. I don't know, she sneaks off and she watches shit. Well, I'm busy doing dumb shit. She says, it's so incredible, Pete.
我不知道你们有没有见过贝蒂·吉尔平，她在我刚完成的作品《美国草莽》里出演，她真是一位极其优秀的演员。顺便说一句，我的妻子阿曼达过去几周也看过了。我不知道，她偷偷摸摸地看这玩意儿。好吧，我正忙着做些蠢事呢。她说，太不可思议了，皮特。
You guys, what's it called again? American Primeval. It's called American Primeval and it's a very violent, very violent show. She says, and you guys both know Amanda very well, and Pete, you know her a bit. She does not give it up. She will not shut up about this.
你们，那叫什么来着？《美国草莽》。这部剧叫《美国草莽》，是一部非常暴力、非常暴力的剧集。她说——你们俩都非常了解阿曼达，皮特你也稍微了解她一点——她绝不会轻易罢休。她对这部剧赞不绝口，停不下来。
Appreciate that, Amanda. This is fantastic, she says. But so, to your question, I recognize if I've made a mistake in casting, and sometimes you do, and usually it's smaller roles, but sometimes it's not. Who, who? I'm not going to say I'm not, I won't mention names.
谢谢你，阿曼达。这太棒了，她说。所以，回到你的问题，我意识到如果我在选角时犯了错误——有时候确实会这样，通常是小角色，但有时也不是。谁？谁？我不会说，我不会提名字。
But you, I can't get, I get frustrated with myself for allowing myself to put someone in a situation that they're just not right for. And I've had moments where I want to get angry with actors and just say, you know, give line readings or just yell at them. Or be better. Yeah, just do it fucking better.
但我会因为自己允许某人处于一个并不适合他们的位置而对自己感到沮丧。我曾经有过这样的时刻，我想对演员发火，只想告诉他们，你知道的，直接念台词或者冲他们大吼。或者表现得更好。是的，就是他妈的做得更好。
Do something. But that unfortunately is not an effective strategy at all. So I've learned enough to know that generally in editing, you can fix things, and oftentimes I've worked with, I've directed actors who I thought were really kind of shitting the bed, and later in editing, I found that they weren't. But in general, I find that getting, as I've gotten older,
做点什么吧。但遗憾的是，这绝不是一个有效的策略。所以我学到了一点：通常在剪辑中你可以解决问题，很多时候我合作过、执导过的演员，我原本以为他们演得像吃了一坨屎一样糟糕，但后来在剪辑时，我发现其实并没有那么糟。但总的来说，我发现随着年龄的增长，
when I did my first movie, Very Bad Things, I was so insecure and confused. And I had Cameron Diaz and Christian Slater at the height of his career, and I was making a movie. If you walked up to me and said, good morning, I would respond with, go fuck yourself. What the fuck does that mean? So much stress.
当我拍摄我的第一部电影《坏坏圣誕夜》时，我是如此缺乏安全感和迷失。当时卡梅隆·迪亚兹和正处于事业巅峰的克里斯蒂安·史莱特都在，而我正在拍一部电影。如果你走到我面前说“早上好”，我的回答会是“去你妈的”。这他妈到底算什么意思？压力太大了。
What does that mean? Have you stress. What does that mean? Have you seen it lately? I just saw the first thing I've directed and it did not hold up. I used to think it was so great. What was it? It was called Bad Words. And there were parts of it,
这到底是什么意思？你有压力。这到底是什么意思？你最近看过这部电影吗？我刚看了我执导的第一部作品，发现它完全经不起时间的考验。我以前觉得它棒极了。那是哪部？那部叫《小谎言》（恶言相向）。里面有些部分，
I was like watching it with my kid the other day, I was like what the fuck was I thinking there? Anyway, there was a lot that I liked, but still. Have you seen Very Bad Things lately? Does it hold up? Not lately, but I've watched it, and it's like I said earlier, I am not happy about how unhappy I was making that film.
前几天我和我孩子一起看的时候，我心想我当时脑子里在想什么呢？不管怎样，里面有很多我喜欢的元素，但依然……你最近看过《坏坏圣誕夜》吗？它经得起考验吗？最近没看，但我看过，就像我刚才说的，对于当年拍那部电影时我是多么的不快乐，我一点也不高兴。
I was just a seething ball of confusion and rage every day. And thank Cameron Diaz for being so sweet. She would pull me into her trailer, and she would watch Uncle Buck in between takes and just I'd walk by her trailer, I'd hear this laughter and it would be Cameron Diaz watching Uncle Buck and she'd be like, Pete, just come and watch Uncle Buck
我每天都是一个充满困惑和愤怒的沸腾火球。感谢卡梅隆·迪亚兹人那么好。她会把我拉进她的拖车里，在拍摄间隙看《巴克叔叔》，我会从她的拖车走过，听到笑声，那就是卡梅隆·迪亚兹在看《巴克叔叔》，她会说，皮特，快来看会儿《巴克叔叔》，
for a little bit and calm down. And I would just sit there trembling watching Uncle Buck and Cameron's laughter calmed me down. She was such an angel to me. That's so fucking, by the way, one of the great line readings of all time, Uncle Buck, is John Kennedy when he's talking to the principal and she's got the wart on her nose.
冷静一下。然后我就会坐在那里颤抖着看《巴克叔叔》，卡梅隆的笑声让我平静了下来。她对我来说简直就是个天使。顺便说一句，那太他妈绝了，《巴克叔叔》里有一句影史最经典的台词，是约翰·肯尼迪在跟校长说话时，校长鼻子上长了个疣。
And he interrupts himself like eight times because he keeps saying, warty nose, warty nose. No, wart on the nose, what? And it's one of the great line readings of all time. Pete, before we let you go, tell us what drew you to American Primeval. This is a show.
他自己打断了自己大约八次，因为他一直在说，有疣的鼻子，有疣的鼻子。不，鼻子上长了个疣，什么？那是影史最经典的台词之一。皮特，在我们让你离开之前，告诉我们是什么吸引你加入了《美国草莽》。这是一部剧，
Can't wait to see it. Yeah. I know. This is a show that is coming out January 9th, I want to say. Yes. Does that sound right? Yes, sir. Yes? January 9th on Netflix, yes. January 9th on Netflix. What. January 9th on Netflix.
迫不及待想看。是的。我知道。这是一部将于 1 月 9 日上映的剧，我想是吧。是的。听起来对吗？是的，先生。是的？1 月 9 日在 Netflix 上线，是的。1 月 9 日在 Netflix 上线。什么。1 月 9 日在 Netflix 上线。
What about it drew you to it? What part of it now that you're done with it do you like the most? Yeah, so I wanted, I'd always wanted to explore the Western world, and I say the Western world because it's not a traditional Western. There was a movie called Jeremiah Johnson that Robert Redford did a long time ago
是什么吸引你加入的？现在拍完了，你最喜欢它的哪个部分？是的，所以我想，我一直想探索西部世界，我说“西部世界”是因为它不是一部传统的西部片。很久以前，罗伯特·雷德福拍过一部叫《鲁宾逊·克鲁索式的山地人》（越过颠峰/杰里米·约翰逊）的电影，
where he played a mountain man, or he played a city man who came to the mountains to try and find gold and he became a mountain man. And he developed a relationship with the Native Americans out there and it was just a really formative movie for me as a kid, my parents took me and I always wanted to do something like that and
他在里面扮演一个山地人，或者说他扮演一个来到山里寻找黄金的城里人，后来成了一个山地人。他和那里的美洲原住民建立了一种关系，对于我小时候来说，这是一部对我影响深远的电影，我的父母带我去看的，我一直想拍一部那样的作品，
Mark L Smith who's a friend of mine who wrote the Revenant And I were talking and I'm like what if we did something in this world? And we started and my goal was I wanted to go out into the elements. I didn't want to shoot in sound stages I wanted to challenge so we ended up with this six-part series That's about a very violent period in American history in 1857, where the Mormons were just starting to have an army and Brigham Young was very violent and they were trying to hold out in Utah. The army was coming after them.
马克·L·史密斯——我的朋友，曾编写过《荒野猎人》——我们在一起聊天，我说，如果我们在这个世界里拍一部作品会怎么样？我们开始了，我的目标是我想走入大自然原生态中。我不想在摄影棚里拍摄，我想挑战自我。所以我们最终拍出了这部六集的剧集，讲述了美国历史上一个非常暴力的时期，即 1857 年，当时摩门教刚刚开始拥有军队，杨百翰非常暴力，他们试图在犹他州坚守阵地。美军正向他们逼近。
Multiple Native American tribes were fighting. And I thought this would be a really interesting environment to set a story. It was a very, very violent time in a very violent history, which is American history, in a very violent global history, which is planet Earth. And we wanted to explore man's innate desire and inability to not kill each other. And we thought that that was just something, living in this world today where obviously violence
多个美洲原住民部落在混战。我觉得这将是一个非常有趣的背景来设定一个故事。这是一个非常、非常暴力的时期，处于一段非常暴力的历史（即美国历史）中，也处于一个非常暴力的全球历史（即地球）中。我们想探索人类内心深处对杀戮的渴望以及无法停止杀戮的无能为力。我们觉得这正是——生活在今天的这个世界上，显然暴力
is on the rise and will it might not all be sugar that got you anxious, like these are rough times, you know? And this is something we wanted to explore. And I think one of the biggest takeaways for me, and this isn't necessarily the sexiest takeaway, but learning about Brigham Young and the history of the Mormon church and how persecuted they were.
正在不断增加，而且威尔，这可能并不全是那些让你焦虑的糖分，这些都是艰难的时期，你知道吗？这是我们想要探讨的东西。我想对我来说最大的收获之一——这不一定是那种最吸引人的收获——但是了解杨百翰和摩门教的历史，以及他们是如何遭受迫害的。
And they were run out of New York and then they were run out of Georgia. And Joseph Smith, the leader, took them up to Illinois to try and create this nabu, this place where they could live. And Joseph Smith was killed. And Brigham Young fled across the country on foot with 2000 of his followers and ended up in what was a God forsaken land,
他们被赶出纽约，然后被赶出佐治亚州。领袖约瑟夫·史密斯带着他们来到伊利诺伊州，试图建立这个纳布，一个他们可以生活的庇护所。结果约瑟夫·史密斯被杀了。杨百翰率领 2000 名追随者徒步逃过全国，最终来到了当时被上帝遗忘的土地——
Salt Lake City at the time. And he said, well, we'll stay here. This is the place. No one will ever come for us here. And he started growing the religion and the US military started coming for him. And the Mormons were a very cunning and at times.S. military started coming for him. And the Mormons were a very cunning and at times violent organization.
当时盐湖城。他说，好吧，我们就待在这里。就是这个地方。这里永远不会有人来找我们。他开始发展这个宗教，而美国军方开始来找他。摩门教徒是一个非常狡猾，有时甚至是暴力的组织。
And one of the things I'm very happy with is actor Kim Coats who plays Brigham Young. He was in Sons of Anarchy and thought I was joking when I cast him as Brigham Young, just a great actor. And learning about that aspect of it was something that for me was just really personally quite interesting. And getting to know the great Betty Gilpin who does such a good job in our show.
我感到非常高兴的一点是，演员金·寇茨饰演杨百翰。他演过《混乱之子》，当我选他演杨百翰时，他还以为我在开玩笑，他真的是个很棒的演员。了解这方面的历史对我来说真的非常有趣。而且还能认识伟大的贝蒂·吉尔平，她在我们的剧中表现得太棒了。
Yeah, that's what Amanda said. And Taylor Kitsch, your- And Taylor, who I love with all my heart. Collaborator, yeah? Yeah, man. Yeah, he's a great actor. Well, I'm fucking thrilled for you. I'm just excited we get more Pete Berg stuff.
是的，阿曼达也是这么说的。还有泰勒·基奇，你的——还有泰勒，我打心底里深爱的泰勒。合作伙伴，对吧？对的，兄弟。是的，他是个伟大的演员。好吧，我他妈为你感到兴奋。我只是很高兴我们能看到更多皮特·博格的作品。
Hopefully you're there in Tel Aviv researching something that's going to be awesome to see one day. Yeah, no kidding. I won't even ask you about it. I know, I've been thinking the whole time. I'm like, what is he doing? I know, exactly. I know.
希望你此时正在特拉维夫研究某种有朝一日会大放异彩的超赞项目。对，可不是嘛。我甚至都不会问你。我知道，我一直在想。我在想，他在干什么？我懂，没错。我懂。
But I miss you, buddy. Hurry back. Let's all hang out. Let's go watch Will's kid go box over your gym bring them in anytime or Sean if you feel like hitting Something come on in Are you getting right after this he's gonna hit the fridge She'd say every day thanks Pete nice to meet Pete love you Every day. Every day.
但我很想念你，兄弟。快回来吧。我们一起聚聚。去看看威尔的孩子在你们健身房打拳，随时带他们来吧。或者肖恩，如果你想打沙包出出气，也随时来。你马上就要去干这个吗？他要去袭击冰箱了。她每天都说，谢谢皮特，很高兴认识皮特，爱你。每天。每天。
Thanks Pete. Nice to meet you Pete. Love you. Great to see you man. She's the only help pal. Thanks for doing this. Congratulations on everything fellas. Keep up the good work.
谢谢你，皮特。很高兴认识你，皮特。爱你。很高兴见到你，伙计。她是唯一的得力助手。谢谢你做这一切。祝贺你们所有人取得的一切成就。继续保持出色的工作。
You're making people really happy and we need that. No thank you. Thank you pal. Thank you. Bye. Bye bye. I'm excited. That was great Jay.
你们让人们感到非常快乐，我们需要这个。不，谢谢你。谢谢你，伙计。谢谢。再见。拜拜。我很兴奋。太棒了，杰伊。
I'm excited for his show, American Prime. It was wild when he came out. I never met him. I think he's like one of the best. He's just the guy, such a great filmmaker. He's a really, really good filmmaker. And you know, he doesn't throw that in the public's face or the industry's face. No. Keeps low profile, you're right.
我为他的剧《美国草莽》感到兴奋。他出场时太狂野了。我以前从没见过他。我觉得他绝对是顶尖人才之一。他就是那种人，一个如此伟大的电影人。他是一个真正、真正优秀的电影人。而且你知道，他不会把这一点挂在公众面前或行业面前。对。保持低调，你说得对。
Yeah, low profile and he's not... He's just making stuff. Yeah, exactly. And every once in a while stuff will show up and you'll go, oh, fuck man, is this fantastic? Nothing ever sucks about what he does. And Jason, you were fantastic in The Kingdom. So good. Jason, you were so good.
对，保持低调，而且他不……他只是在踏实做作品。对，没错。而且每隔一段时间就会有作品问世，你会感叹，操，伙计，这也太棒了吧？他的作品从来没有什么烂片。杰森，你在《反恐王国》里的表现太棒了。太棒了。杰森，你演得太好了。
I remember loving that movie. I loved that movie. I thought that movie was fucking great. Yeah, it was scary. It was like one of those rare ones that was like all... It was so good. I'm telling you, that line reading, I saw it in the theater with Kraz, with Krasinski.
我记得我很喜欢那部电影。我太喜欢那部电影了。我觉得那部电影他妈的太棒了。是的，很吓人。那是那种罕见的、整体都……太棒了。我跟你说，那句台词，我是跟克拉兹——和卡辛斯基一起在电影院看的。
And yeah, we did, we saw it in New York, and you delivered that line, we were fucking. Are you late? Are you late? No doubt. It was so fucking good. I can't wait that, it's called American Primeval. American Primeval, correct.
没错，我们在纽约看的，你念那句台词时，我们他妈的……你迟到了吗？你迟到了吗？毫无疑问。太他妈棒了。我等不及了，那部剧叫《美国草莽》。《美国草莽》，没错。
Sometimes in January, go on the Netflix. Yeah. Or the reflux. Yeah. Yeah. Sean, I don't see you looking off to your P.I. show. I know, Sean, this is a fun day. I wasn't prepared.
有时在一月份，去网飞看看。对。或者反流。对。对。肖恩，我没看见你在看你的私家侦探节目。我知道，肖恩，今天是开心的一天。我没有准备。
I wasn't prepared. You're not prepared. That's why. I'm nervous. So we're going to stall a little bit while you pull, now I see him looking around all the different windows Possible by possible by Whole thing with Gary Shanandling. Yeah.
我没有准备。你没有准备。这就是原因。我很紧张。所以我们要拖延一会儿，而你在搜索，现在我看到他在所有可能的不同窗口里环顾四周。加里·尚德林的那整件事。对。
The whole boxing thing with Bob Dylan. That was really funny. That was a story that I was really blown away. Buying? Buying. Buying. Good. Huh.
和鲍勃·迪伦的那整个拳击事件。那真的很有趣。那是一个真正让我大开眼界的历史。买入？买入。买入。很好。哈。
Okay. The problem with that is that it's so close. It's so on the nose that to be honest for me, I just don't buy it. That will work. You know what I mean? Two half ones make a full. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
好吧。问题在于它太接近了。太直白了，说实话对我不受用，我就是不买账。那样行得通。你知道我的意思吗？两个半个合起来就是一个完整的。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。
Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。少一点。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。